So, jetzt warten wir mal bis Twitch kapiert, dass der Stream on ist, das dauert ja immer
kurz.
Ok, das Stream ist on, hast du sowas, gab es die Benachrichtigung im Discord oder gab
es die Benachrichtigung über Twitch?
Ah, du warst zufällig auf der Seite, ok, weil es sind gerade 3 Leute da und 2 davon
sehe ich im Chat, also ich glaube Twitch hat so nicht mitgekriegt, dass der Stream wirklich
on ist.
Worts runterladen, sehr gute Idee, exquisite, ja ich muss Hetzan am nächsten Rechnung schicken
für das Jahr fällt mir gerade ein, dann muss ich nochmal gucken, wie viele Streams wann
gegeben hat.
Ist gut, dass du die runterlegst, sonst müsste ich irgendwo in der Historie rumkramen.
Moin Timo, so, wir machen mal kurz die VM an, oder wie manch coole Leute sagen, we
am, wir hatten mal einen auf der Arbeit, der hat immer gesagt, we am, der hat nicht die
VM gestartet, hat die VM gestartet, das habe ich glaube ich schon 50 mal erzählt, aber
ich finde die Betonung bloß so geil, we am.
Genau Recycle Story.
Twitch Message kam jetzt ah, nice, ok.
Dann hat es Twitch ja mittlerweile kapiert.
Und Discord hat es auch verstanden, ja wunderbar, exellent.
Ja, die Spielerzahlen gehen aber noch gerade ne, die sind nur 50% Downside released, also
die Spielerzahlen gehen echt noch, gehen echt noch halbwegs klar hier, oh, ich hab
nix gesagt, letztens wo ich geguckt hab, war 24 Hour Peak noch 50, ok, ich hab nix
gesagt, RIP, die haben 2 Drittel verloren, alles klar, nice, GG Eats, gut gemacht EA,
vielleicht ja, da bin ich mir nur nicht ganz sicher, das kann durchaus sein, dass es darauf
rausläuft, ich will mir mal ein paar dieser Dinger angucken und ich sag gleich, ich sag
gleich was zu, wenn der Stream so richtig, wenn die Leute genug Chancen hatten zu gucken.
Ah stimmt, wenn, wenn, wenn, steams, Moment, das gibt es nicht mehr, das gibt es nicht
mehr über Steam, gell, das ist ja, das ist ja Battle.net mittlerweile, Abofade, so ist
richtig, exellent.
Ja, ich glaub, da wird es drauf rauslaufen, also was ich jetzt gesehen habe, sind folgende
Sachen, es gibt SteppingNG, dann irgendwas was sich Gathos nennt und Kuma Abtime, das
hab ich so, hab ich vorhin gefunden auf irgendeinem Self-hosted Reddit-Thread, wo die Leute das
vorgeschlagen haben und vom ersten Blick sieht Abtime Kuma tatsächlich am besten aus, ich
mein, es hat vielleicht Abtime Kuma, vielleicht, wenn man das falsch verstehen will von der
Betonung her, bisschen unglücklichen Namen, aber ansonsten scheint das wirklich ganz gut
zu sein, wir gucken uns das mal schnell an.
Ja, ist so, also ich bin echt gespannt, ob da noch was kommt, weil viele Leute sagen
ja nach dem Motto, nach dem Motto, Max, das kann ja gar nicht sein, das kam ja alles
verbackt raus, warte mal ein halbes Jahr ab, achja, und das geilste Comment hab ich gestern
gelesen, hat er gesagt, hat irgendjemand geschrieben, Moment, du kannst den Ticken leiser, hat
irgendjemand geschrieben, ja LUL, wer ist so nach dem Motto, LUL, wer ist denn hier der
eigentliche Noob, du bist der Noob, weil du hast dir Battlefield zum Release gekauft und
es ist doch bekannt, dass man Battlefield erst ein halbes Jahr später kaufen könnte,
also muss ich das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, man ist ein Noob, wenn man das Spiel
zu dem Zeitpunkt spielen will, zu dem der Hersteller sagt, das Spiel ist raus, alles
klar, das heißt die eigentlichen, die eigentlichen Pros, das heißt die eigentlichen richtig
krassen Pros, die kaufen dann quasi erst, wenn das Spiel down ist auf 5000 User, oder
wie, das hab ich schon nicht verstanden, also ich glaub auch nicht, dass sie die Karre
nochmal aus dem Dreck kriegen, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, glaub ich nicht, glaub das
ist in Brunnen gefallen, das ist vorbei, ohje, wir haben 88 Zuschauer, jetzt kann die Verschwörungstheorie
Leute wiederkommen, das aktuelle Call of Duty hab ich auch nicht gekauft, das hat mich von
Anfang an null angesprochen und spricht mich immer noch nicht an, aber die werden es raus
reisen mit dem Warzone Update, ich sag's euch, oh ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, bloß nicht, bloß
nicht, bloß nicht, reddit ist ja auch lustig, es gibt ja das Subreddit für Battlefield
2042 und das Battlefield Subreddit und es war bisher immer so, dass so das Battlefield
Subreddit hat das quasi gefeiert und das Battlefield 2042 hat so ein bisschen gehatet
und die haben es dann immer richtig schön gezopft, mittlerweile ist es aber so, dass
auch die Stimmung auf dem normalen Battlefield Reddit ein bisschen umschlägt, ach Portal,
ach das ist, das ist totgeburt, das ist gelaufen die Sache, vielleicht kriegen sie es noch
halbwegs hin, dass da noch irgendwas, irgendwas die Leute, irgendwas halbwegs spielbares
für ihre 80, 100 oder 120, was kosten die teuerste Version da kriegen, aber ich glaube,
wie gesagt, der Zug, dass es wirklich mal so Battlefield 4 Nachfolge antreten wird, kann
ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, wisst ihr was ich noch lustiger finde, ich hab ja damals
als Battlefield 3 am Start war, mich übelst über Suppression und sowas aufgeregt, hab
ich gewusst, was da noch kommt, dann hätte ich mal eine Klappe gehalten, das konnte ja
damals keiner ahnen und auch bei Battlefield 4 habe ich richtig krass rumgeflammt am Anfang,
aber gut, das war ja auch kaputt, aber hätte ich mal gewusst, was da noch kommt, dann hätte
ich mir eher gedacht, oh wie schön ist das hier, aber das weiß natürlich nicht, du bist
ja immer, nachher bist du ja immer schlauer, ja, oder, oder für 20-42 FPS habe ich auch
schon gelesen, ich mach mal kurz meine VM an, ach hier, ne, hab ich ja voll schon angemacht,
damn, exzellent, ich beleg grad, ob wir das auf dem Raspberry Pi testen sollen oder ob
wir das einfach in der VM testen, in der VM testen ist einfacher, Raspberry Pi müsste
ich jetzt erstmal flashen, wobei, ich flash mal nebenbei den Raspberry Pi, weil, warum
ist mein Launcher eigentlich in so ner Kackfarbe, bei mir auf der anderen VM hat das ne ordentliche
Farbe und hier nicht, da ist irgendwas, irgendwas kaputt, downcrate das jetzt einfach, wobei,
ich mach mal kurz, ich mach mal kurz ein Update, wo wir grad dabei sind, ich hab schon ne ganze
Weile meine VM hier nicht mal geupdatet, wie, was, wie das was, wirklich, was maß, ich
will mich jetzt da nicht beschweren, dass ich mehr Updates machen muss als, aber ich hab
das doch schon ne ganze Weile nicht mal geupdatet, was machst du mal in Beitrag zu nem, ehm,
haben wir doch schon gemacht, das ist noch gar nicht so lang her, wir haben, wir haben
in, warte mal, warte mal, mal gucken, ob es sogar noch in der Historie drin ist, guck
mal, wir haben doch hier, Moment, ja vielleicht, Calcuate, meine Titel sind manchmal ein bisschen
blöd, da versteht man nicht so genau, um was es geht, was soll man sich bitte schon unter
Calcuate vorstellen, hier, hier, guck mal, so, da haben wir das, da haben wir das doch
gemacht, wo, wo ist der, da, hier, da, da liegen auch die LEDs, hier haben wir die Steckdose
gemacht, hier liegt, hier liegt die LED, hier liegen die LEDs, äh, jetzt mach ich irgendwo
Löt, Löt, Lötställs, achja, genau, da wird's in den Anschluss dran gelötet, alles klar,
passt doch, sind wir doch grad dabei, also den Stream musst du dir angucken, und irgendwo
am Ende zeig ich dann auch wie das Webinterface aussieht, äh, da, ne, da, da zeige ich, wenn
die LEDs ansehen, ich meine, die sind aufgerollt, kein Wunder, dass es so kacke aussieht, so
und jetzt zeige ich das Webinterface dafür, guck, da kann man hier, kann man hier rumstellen,
ah, funktioniert ja alles, das ist aber insgesamt ziemlich, äh, also es ist erstaunlich simpel,
so was anzuschließen, du brauchst einen Controller, am besten irgendeinen x-bliebigen ESP32 oder
ESP866, 5 Volt Netzteil, und du schließt das einfach an und flasht WLED drauf, das war's
in 95% der Fälle, WLAN noch danach, ja, einstellen, tja, übrigens, was auch eine sehr merkwürdige
Theorie ist, irgendjemand in den Kommentaren hat geschrieben, die Leute fantasieren sich
ja immer so Sachen zusammen, vor allem wenn man da technisch nicht so versiert ist, ähm,
kommen da komische Sachen raus, dazu hat nämlich auch in den Kommentaren bei mir einer was
geschrieben hat gesagt, Max, das mit dem Lobby disbanden nach jeder Runde, das muss so sein,
damit man alle Serverinstanzen vollkriegt, das ist totaler Schwachsinn, ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen, dass die, dass die im Jahr 2021 noch statische Serverinstanzen haben,
das wird diagonal und vertikal und horizontal und hoch und runter skaliert, die haben genauso
viele Server laufen, wie die Spieler haben, mit ein bisschen Verzögerung natürlich, aber
die haben bestimmt nicht 80% Leerlauf-Server laufen nachts oder sowas, das ist ja unsinnig,
viel Geld verschwendet und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass so ein Battlefield-Server an sich, Battlefield-Server
ist ja ziemlich self-contained, da brauchst du keine Datenbank oder sonst was, wo der permanent
Sachen macht, die kannst du, das kannst du wahrscheinlich wunderbar, container-mäßig,
cluster-mäßig, äh, scalen, Battlefield-Server, gehe ich mal stark von aus.
Unik, danke für den Sub, hehe, ja, bei mir ist ja kein Homeoffice bis Januar, ich hab
jetzt erstmal Urlaub, seit 2 Wochen oder so, früher, den Monat noch, gar nicht, wie gesagt
gar nicht.
Was würdest, was würde, würdest du für eine Logging-UI für Linux-Services, Logs, Logging-UI?
Vim, Less und Vim oder Tail oder, aber Logging-UI, was meinste, ach du meinst zum zentralen,
du meinst so was wie LogsDash oder sowas, zum zentralen einsammeln und dann durchsuchen?
Ach so, tja, ich kenn bloß LogsDash, LogsDash ist ja die Elasticsearch-Geschichte, da kann
ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so viel zu sagen, hehe, das ist eigentlich so der standard Vim-Joke,
aber der zieht immer noch, ich muss euch sagen, ich hab das am Anfang auch nicht gecheckt,
wisst ihr, was ich ganz am Anfang gemacht habe, wenn ich Vim geöffnet hab, aus Versehen
meistens, aus Versehen, also ganz, ganz, ganz am Anfang, das war ja natürlich unter Ubuntu
im grafischen Terminal, ich hab einfach das Fenster zugeklickt, wo Vim drin lief und jedes
Mal, wenn ich die Datei dann wieder öffnen wollte, in Vim hat er gesagt, es sind noch
temporäre Files offen und damals hab ich gesagt, man, ist das ein scheiß Editor, sogar Word
Kick das besser hin, hab ich gesagt, das kann doch nicht sein, bis ich dann irgendwann
mal mich ein bisschen mit beschäftigt hab und dann festgestellt, ok, eigentlich ist
das, ist das ziemlich gut und mittlerweile ist Vim eigentlich, wenn ich so, so Admin-Sachen
machen, konsolenmäßig, SSH oder was auch immer, SSH und sonst was, benutze ich eigentlich
fast ausschließlich Vim, Craylock ist auch gut, ja, das hab ich, das hab ich, hat nicht
der, hat nicht der Niklas erzählt im Video, also Herr Endpunkt, hat er nicht im Video
erzählt, dass der Craylock aufgesetzt hat als Abschlussprojekt, ich, ich bilde mir,
ich bilde mir ein, das, da war irgendwas, ach guck mal, Updates sind durch, POG ist
eigentlich, wo wir gerade da, oh nee, jetzt hab ich das wieder geupdatet, ist eigentlich,
wo wir gerade dabei sind, RIDER, RIDER 21.3, die kriegen es nicht gebacken, oh, das wollte
ich gar nicht updaten, ich wollte, ich wollte Check for Updates machen, lul, verklippt,
ich wollte auch übrigens mal kurz meinen Raspberry Pi schnell flashen, das machen
wir, dann machen wir das Ganze auf den Raspberry Pi, das geht ja zack, ich dauere ja 5 Minuten,
SD-Karte holen, äh, SD-Karten-Leser hier, zack, das muss ich euch jetzt nicht großartig
zeigen, das haben wir schon 85.000 Millionen, Michael 50 Billionfach gemacht, ey, das ist
immer noch nicht raus, der ist spannend, downgrade, must be root, ja, ja, das da, oh, oh, zack,
ah, guck, jetzt ist es auch alles wieder Darkseam, ich weiß bis heute nicht, warum das nicht
Darkseam ist, na gut, also ich flash mal kurz meinen Raspberry Pi, hat er das jetzt eingehängt
oder nicht, Transcend, da ist es doch, äh, oh, wie ist das, Pi Image, oh, ne, ihr werdet
niemand Passwort erraten übrigens, da kommt ihr nicht drauf, was mein Root-Passwort ist,
das ist nicht erratbar für euch, choose Operating System, Raspberry Pi, nein, light, wie sieht
es eigentlich aus, ist mittlerweile eigentlich Raspberry, äh, Raspberry Pi Dings Standard
64 Bit, äh, quasi schon released oder ist das immer noch nicht raus, weil zur Auswahl
ist das hier nicht, sehr merkwürdig, ne, deshalb, die haben, glaub, standardmäßig,
keine Ahnung, was muss man drücken, Shift, Control, X, ne, oder, ach, was ist das für
Hacker-Man-Kram, warum nimmst du keinen Arch, das ist ein Arch, ach, du meinst auch Raspberry
Pi drauf, ne, ne, Alter, das ist ja mir richtig Hacker-Man-Shit hier, aber das bringt mir
ja nix, ich will da 64, ich wollte da 64 Bit, das mag ja, das mag ja ganz nett sein, ok,
Enable SSH ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch, das finde ich tatsächlich gut, WiFi konfigurieren
müssen wir nicht, ja, ich brauche kein, ich schließe das per Kabel an, ne, wird hier irgendwas
geleakt, na gut, also wir machen das Light-Dings drauf, äh, funktioniert Docker, stellt es
eigentlich gescheit auf den Raspberry Pi mittlerweile, ich hatte das letzte Mal, wo ich da ein bisschen
mit rum experimentiert habe, Probleme, ich kann mich aber gar nicht mehr erinnern, welche
das genau waren, yes, was, ne, doch, doch, yes, jetzt, schreib mal, aber ansonsten machen
wir es einfach auf der VM, ist ja kein Problem, aber ich dachte mir, wenn ich schon mal am
Raspberry Pi 4 hier stehen habe, können wir es auch da machen, das, das ist glaube ich
relativ einfach, ja, man muss glaube ich einfach nur 64 Bit Kernel drauf klatschen oder so,
das haben wir ja schon ein paar mal gemacht sogar, 64 Bit Trespian, aber wozu, Docker
stellt es, äh, Docker, KVM macht Probleme, das weiß ich, KVM haben wir ja auch mal versucht
zum Laufen zu bekommen, das ging nicht richtig, Assem Shield, oh, wird der Hacker-Man-Kram
hier angesagt, seh ich schon, Chat ist wieder einfach way too schlau, ach ja, ich, beider
gelegen, während das gerade flasht, kann ich mal, kann ich mal was zeigen, also, was
ich, was ich machen will ist folgendes, Restore Session, oh ne, China, Chinesen, AliExpress,
Black Friday Deals, die können wir wegmachen, also, äh, was ich, was ich gefunden habe
ist folgendes, ähm, oder ich muss, ich muss, ich muss anders anfangen, was ich eigentlich
machen will, ich will ein Dashboard haben, so ein, ein Monitoring-Dashboard, was mir
einfach anzeigt, ob meine Hosts up oder down sind und paar ganz simple Checks kann, so
irgendwas, was möglichst easy für daheim ist, wo man sich überhaupt nicht weiter mit
beschäftigen muss und wo man vor allem nicht viel, ähm, oh je, wo man nicht viel Wartungsarbeiten,
äh, wo man nicht viel Wartungs dran machen muss, genau, so, was ich gefunden habe ist
folgendes, ich hab das hier gefunden, SteppingNG, das da hab ich gefunden und UptimeKuma hab
ich gefunden, das war echt ein unglücklicher Name, Alter, stell dir mal vor, irgendjemand
verkauft UptimeKuma über Banggood, so, und aktuell hab ich folgendermaßen, Cashet hab
ich auch gefunden, nee, das ist eher für, äh, Status-Seiten, um, äh, quasi nach außen
hin zu sagen, mein Service ist jetzt up und down und sonst wie, das ist, glaub ich, nicht
so, nicht, nicht so, die zwei Sachen hab ich gefunden, noch ein anderes, das hat aber kacke
ausgesehen, so, wie ich aktuell habe, also, ich zeig euch mal eine Demo-Seite, wie das
dann aus, aussieht im Endeffekt, man hat da ne Seite, ah, super, das ist ne Kack-Kack-Demo-Seite,
aber, haben die ne bessere Demo, ja, so was hier, also, so sieht das dann aus, man hat
da ne Dashboard und kann dann einfach so simple Sachen machen, wie HTTP-Checks oder TCP-Checks,
Pingen, Zertifika, ich hoffe, dass die, dass die Zertifikatläufen laufen aus-Checks haben,
so, aktuell mach ich das folgendermaßen, und jetzt kann ich euch nämlich auch erklären,
warum ich das, warum ich das machen will, ja, also, Jack, Jack MK2 gibt's ja mittlerweile
jetzt ne neue Version von seit ein paar Tagen, dann hat irgendjemand noch Zabbix geschrieben
und dein Zeug, also, wie ich das aktuell hab, ist folgendermaßen, ich hab ein Prometheus
mit Grafana, dazu brauchste halt die üblichen Verdächtigen, du musst gucken, wie du deine
Host discoverst, du musst schauen, oder machst halt Hostlisten im YAML-Format, du brauchst
wie gesagt irgendwelche Inventory-Listen, du brauchst YAML-Files zur Config, du brauchst
bei, gerade bei der Prometheus-Grafana-Kombi noch irgendwelche Blackbox-Exporter, weil
das halt eigentlich gar nicht so für da gedacht ist, simple Sachen wie Up und Down zu checken,
auch Grafana, so ein simples Dashboard, Host ist Up oder Down, ist komplizierter, als man
sich das denken mag, weil du unterscheiden musst zwischen Agent Up, Agent Down, Ping
ist da, Ping ist nicht da, weil es kann ja durchaus sein, dass Agent, Agent Up ist,
aber irgendein anderer checkt da nicht, da musst du das mal miteinander verbinden, dafür
ist das schlicht und ergreifend nicht gedacht, es geht, aber schön ist das nicht, und ich
hab beispielsweise im Grafana so Dinger drin, wie Festplatten-Auslastung vom Videorecorder
oder sowas, Videorecorder ist bescheuert deswegen, wo man Sachen aufnehmen kann mit,
oder Zertifikat läuft ab in, mit so einem Graph, dass ich das sehen kann, dafür ist
Grafana ganz nice, wenn man die Sachen visualisiert haben will, wenn man irgendwie bisschen mehr
Sachen hat als ist okay, ist nicht okay, und das gefällt mir für den lokalen Einsatzzweck
bei mir nicht, weil ich will eigentlich kaum was machen, ich will bei mir noch nicht mal
irgendwie großartig Service Discovery machen und sagen, hey alles was in dieser Liste drin
steht soll überwacht werden, weil ganz ehrlich, 99% meiner Sachen die ich hier daheim habe
läuft ohne einen Mux zu machen, und ich hab so ein paar Dinger, die machen öfters mal
Probleme, zum Beispiel der Raspberry Pi, der am Hoftor ist für die Kamera, und den
will ich eigentlich einfach nur pingen, oder im besten Fall einen TCP-Check machen, ob
der Port für den Stream noch offen ist, das ist alles, solche simple Dinger, das gibt
dann am Ende vielleicht 15 Checks oder so, und das war's, und dann einfach ein simples
Dashboard ist up ist down, fertig, so, warum ich die anderen Sachen nicht nehme liegt
schlicht und ergreifend daran, weil, wo fangen wir an, Zappix haben wir auf der Arbeit, Zappix
ist eine coole Geschichte, aber Zappix ist halt auch wirklich brainfuck, bis man da durchblickt,
also zumindest ich streike sehr mühsam nur durch Zappix durch, wie man da was macht,
außerdem finde ich das auch ziemlich overkill für 15 Checks daheim, die im Prinzip Ping-Checks
und ist der Port auf-Check sind, und vielleicht mal ein läuft das Zertifikat ab.
Checkmk ist auch ganz cool, aber auch viel zu groß für das, was ich haben will, außerdem
muss ich sagen, Checkmk ist, ich glaube das ist mittlerweile nicht mehr Nagios basiert,
aber trotzdem, ich finde das auch nicht schön, schön anzugucken.
Da gibt's ja noch mehr, von Libre, NMS bis sonst was, gibt ja total viele solche Oldschool
Monitoring Lösungen, aber die finde ich alle entweder zu aufgeblasen für mich daheim oder
zu kompliziert, vor allem bei den meisten braucht man dann irgendwie noch extra Datenbank
dazu, extra Frontend, bei manchen Monitoring Lösungen sind super abgedreht, die brauchen
dann, versuch mal Zappix im Docker zum Laufen zu kriegen, da brauchst du 5 Kisten, eine
Datenbank, irgendeinen Runner, irgendein Frontend-Ding, ach das ist alles Crap.
Also das ist mir alles zu kompliziert für daheim, wie gesagt, aktuell hab ich Prometheus
mit Grafana vorne dran, das ist für Metrix Sachen ja richtig cool, zum Beispiel, dass
ich den Verlauf sehen kann von Festplatten Benutzung bei Videorekorder oder die Zertifikate
wie die Expiren oder solche Geschichten oder Statistiken zu meiner Heizung und sowas, da
ist Grafana ja richtig nice, aber ich will einfach nur wissen, ist Up, ist Down, fertig,
das reicht, ja mit Node-RED fang ich nicht an, ja, ich hab schon 20 Videos aufgenommen,
die muss ich nur noch hochladen, ja sowas selbst programmieren ist sicherlich eine
coole Sache, ja das will ich ausprobieren, das hab ich nämlich bei denen auf GitHub gelesen,
wir benutzen das auf der Arbeit auch, wir benutzen auf der Arbeit eine Kombination aus Zappix,
Prometheus und Grafana, das ist schon eine coole Geschichte, Prometheus und Grafana
glänzen halt an der Stelle wo du beispielsweise irgendwelche selbst programmierten Java Backends
hast, die Metriken exportieren, da ist das richtig geil, da kannst du gucken wann ist
der Garbage-Collector zuletzt gelaufen, was wurde freigegeben, wie ist der Connection
cool zu den Datenbanken, was weiß ich, wie ist die RAM-Auslastung, wie sind Worker, Prozesse
ausgelastet, alles mögliche, für sowas ist Prometheus gut, für so Standard Sachen ich
will wissen ob meine Kamera am Hoftor noch pingt, vielleicht etwas overkill, aber so
hab ich es aktuell auch, ja das probieren wir gesagt gleich aus und sowas zu programmieren
ist sicherlich cool aber ich hab keinen Bock, ich bin mittlerweile auf dem Trip das ich sag
hey was es fertig gibt und wo es keinen kompletten Dealbreaker, Showstopper ist glaube ich das
Stonks Marketing Wort dafür, also wenn es irgendwie was gibt was schon jemand anderes
gebaut hat, was halbwegs maintained ist und was nicht irgendwas überhaupt nicht kann
was ich haben will nehme ich mittlerweile fertige Sachen, der einzige Grund warum ich noch selbst
für die Kameras was mit WebRTC gebaut hab ist, weil diese ganzen Projekte die RTSP-Kamera
zu WebRTC machen, sucken, ich hab noch kein gutes gefunden, solang verwende ich halt meins
bis da mal einer was macht, meins ist ja auch relativ simpel, das ist ein bisschen Go,
ein bisschen C-Sharp und ein bisschen JavaScript, also da verwende ich eigenes Zeug aber ansonsten
verwende ich mittlerweile zum größten Teil das was fertig ist, Bookstack hat mir nicht
gefallen weil du eine Datenbank brauchst anstatt dass es die Dinger Plain Text ablegt, ich
mag Wiki Sachen die Plain Text die ganzen Seiten ablegen, ja das ist ja relativ simpel,
an sich ist es auch relativ simpel, es wird aber mit den Details kompliziert, wie viele
Notifications Sachen willst du unterstützen, du möchtest die Sachen möglichst dynamisch
wenig Hardcoded machen was es auch oftmals viel viel aufwendiger macht als wenn du halt
schon den ganz spezifischen Einsatzzweck kennst, da kannst du es einfach genauso bauen wie
du brauchst und links und rechts alles liegen lassen, wenn du ein ordentliches Webinterface
noch dazu brauchst, also sowas wächst mit den Details, so hat es jetzt eigentlich fertig
geflasht, also sowas hier, sowas, also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher mit was ich zum
ausprobieren anfangen soll, ob wir als erstes mal SteppingNG testen oder ob wir Uptime Kuma
testen, Leute was, ihr habt das doch bestimmt schon ausprobiert, was sollen wir ausprobieren
zuerst, ich glaube das ist besser oder, ich glaube wenn man das ausprobiert haben können
wir uns das andere eigentlich sparen, Uptime GachiBuzz probieren wir mal aus, jawoll, you
can now remove the SD card from the reader, wir remove es from the reader, also continue,
reader, blibblim, so ich stöpsel mal kurz den Raspberry Pi an, GitHub hat auch ne Demopage
da, aber das brauchen wir nicht, wisst ihr was Paynes Champ ist, wenn die SD Karte euch
in das Gehäuse vom Raspberry Pi rein fällt und ihr nicht mehr dran kommt, aber ist mir
zum Glück nicht passiert, oh mein Switch hat keinen Strom, was ist denn jetzt hier das
Netzteil vom Switch hier, Switch, rein da, gib ihm, kurz warten bis der Switch gebootet
ist, erinnert mich immer wenn ich sag Switch, muss ich mich da dran erinnern, wo mal unser
Infrastruktur Netzwerk Dienstleister auf der Arbeit ist mal auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen
und hat seinen Support bzw. seine, wie nennt man das, Eskalations, also die die melden
wenn was kaputt ist, hat das mal outsourced zu irgendeinem tschechischen, zu irgendeiner
tschechischen Hotline, die, das war so ne Meta Hotline, die konnte man quasi buchen und
dort haben dann für 20 verschiedene Unternehmen die Leute angerufen bei der Hotline und dann
ist irgendwie mal ein Switch ausgefallen in irgendeine Etage, das weiß ich noch, das kam
dann beim Support raus, ihr wisst ja ich sitz relativ in der Nähe vom Support und ich krieg
den ganzen Kram immer mit und die haben dann versucht da anzurufen und haben gesagt, ja
hier ist ein Switch kaputt und dann musste die allen Ernstes musste der der Switch buchstabieren
an der Hotline, also das war wirklich eines der Paynes Champigsten Support Erfahrungen
die ich so mitbekommen habe, was ist kaputt, eine Switch, was ist eine Switch, wie schreibt
man eine Switch, ich sag euch, das hat 20 Minuten gedauert bis sie überhaupt gecheckt
hat wo die hin muss, ja aber wahrscheinlich war nichts billig, also ich mein für Qualität
kostet halt, so der Raspberry Pi sollte eigentlich booten, jop und während der Raspberry Pi bootet,
wenn ich Glück habe, hat der Raspberry Pi noch die gleiche IP vom letzten Mal, schauen
wir mal, ich schau mal nebenbei, ich schau mal nebenbei ins DHCP rein, ob sich da irgendwas
tut, leases, äh, macht das jetzt was, Switch, Pi, macht ihr irgendwas, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, ja, ich glaube, der leckt critical information, kann das sein?
Ah ne, der leckt keine critical information.
Der funktioniert ja.
Ok nice, das ist ja schon mal schön.
Keine Reservierung, na ich glaube die hier ist das.
Deswegen hatte ich ja noch in der history.
So und das wichtigste, Leute was ist das erste was man machen muss, wenn man sich auf den
Raspberry Pi eingeloggt hat, um sich später nerviges Passwortgetippe zu ersparen.
Wer erinnert sich noch an die ganzen restlichen Streams, was ist das erste was man machen muss?
So und jetzt muss man genau einmal das Passwort eingeben und ab jetzt kann man sich immer
ohne Passwort einloggen.
Und danach kann man vielleicht noch das Login deaktivieren oder das Passwort ändern, wobei
ich ganz ehrlich, Test Raspberry Pi juckt ja nicht.
Was gelernt, siehste, dafür ist das Stream da und deswegen ist es auch so, dass jeder
Prime-Sub einen IQ Punkt für den gesamten Chat gibt, deswegen sind alle hier mittlerweile
so extrem schlau und feilfett und high IQ.
Und willst du noch Neo-Fetch sehen, was hat der jetzt hier für, hä, was will der denn
jetzt von mir, ok, Upgrade, dann mach mal, gib ihm, so, danach installieren wir noch
so ein paar Standard-Tools, die man eigentlich immer braucht, die meisten sind auf dem Raspberry
Pi nämlich schon drauf, sowas wie Hardtop und sowas, aber es gibt trotzdem ein paar
Dinge, die ich ganz gern hab, drauf installiert hab.
Ich hab gern einen vollständigen Vim drauf installiert, Hardtop, T-Mags und JIT, wobei
das meiste eh schon drauf ist, glaub, am Raspberry Pi und die Build-Essentials, dass man im Zweifelsfall
irgendwas kompilieren kann, ist ja wieder High-Speed angesagt hier, Huge-Geschwindigkeit.
Was ist das, warum geht meine Maus nicht?
Ah, also am zweiten Rechner, keine Ahnung, warum die nicht funktioniert.
Im Homeoffice Stream gucken, also im Prinzip für Streams, ja, vielleicht kannst du das
irgendwie als, wenn du was mit Niedrigungstun hast, vielleicht kannst du das irgendwie
als Weiterbildungs-Schulungsmaßnahmen oder so verschleiern.
Was heißt, vollständiges Vim gibt's auch kaputt, ne, ja, es gibt verschiedene Varianten,
das zeig ich dir gleich, mit verschieden vielem Zeugs dabei.
Standard ist, glaub ich, nur der Tiny Vim drauf, wobei ich bei der Raspberry Pi gar
nicht so sicher bin.
Mit dem M-Core, ne, mit dem M-Core habe ich schon eine Weile nicht mehr gesprochen, aber
wir wollten was zusammen aufnehmen.
Terminal mehr fällt nicht auf, das stimmt, das ist eine gute Idee.
Auf, mein Gott, Raspberry Pi, mach doch mal hinne, guck mal hier, der Colonel Hacker ist
am Start.
Seid ihr, Chet, seid ihr schon drin?
Chet wird da eingehackermänt.
Captain Sieker, dankeschön, 19 Monate, huge subscription hier.
Wusste es gar nicht, dass der Mesh noch Videos macht, ja, ich auch nicht.
Also ich wusste, dass es ihn interessiert, weil wir ein bisschen im Discord geschrieben
haben.
Ich bin mir aber gar nicht sicher, ob er mehr als die, der hat das gleiche Problem wie ich
gehabt.
Der hat auch zugesagt, dass er diese Sponsored-Videos von EA macht und im Endeffekt hat ihn das
Game abgefuckt.
Deswegen hat er glaube ich erst mal nur die drei Sponsored-Videos gemacht, weil ihm nichts
anderes übrig geblieben ist.
Was willst du machen, ja?
Pi, was macht der da eigentlich?
Was treibt es hier eigentlich gerade?
Removing Diversion, oh, Diverse wird removed.
Das geht aber nicht, da sind bestimmt ein paar Leute triggert heutzutage, wenn man das
postet auf Twitter, dann ist es aber vorbei, dann wird der Raspberry Pi geshitstormt.
So, ja ich glaube er hat es geschafft, ok, Art Insta, also guck mal, Wim gibt es in folgenden
Varianten Wim Tiny, gibt es Wim Tiny, das ist glaube ich der Standard, ich weiß aber
nicht, ob das der Standard unter Raspberry-Pi-Debian ist, muss ich sagen, was, ach der ist da gar
nicht ruf, ich dachte eigentlich, das ist mittlerweile der Standard, aber ist es nicht,
Nano?
Oh Gott, für die Noobs, Alter, das ist ja fast wie in Battlefield, Nano Default ist
ja fast wie Scoreboard entfernen, ok, also, also du hast verschiedene Wim Geschichten
dabei, du hast einmal den Tiny Wim, das ist glaube ich standardmäßig sogar, wenn du Wim
installierst, oder du hast Full, war es Full, nee, aber du hast auf jeden Fall Wim GTK oder
was, g-wim, ah meine Güte, was weiß ich für die ganzen Packages hier, ah Wim GTK,
Wim GTK hast du, ach, ach jetzt weiß ich auch warum der nicht auto-completed, weil ich
das install weggelassen habe, Wim Fador, also kannst du den Wim GTK installieren, aber
ich dachte, ich bilde mir einen, es gibt doch Wim Full, aber gibt es anscheinend nicht,
das hier sind übrigens alles irgendwelche Wim Plugins, Wim Common gibt es noch, genau,
also ich installiere tatsächlich auch im grafischen, meistens ganz gerne den GTK Wim, weil da ist
wirklich alles dabei, aber wir können auch einfach so machen, das reicht auch, ich glaube
Neo Wim gibt es da gar nicht, wir können mal kurz gucken, ob es auch Neo Wim gibt,
ich glaube nicht, doch, tatsächlich gibt es, ist ja interessant, ok, so zumindest können
wir jetzt schon mal Dateien ordentlich editieren, das ist doch schon mal nice, so, abinstall
JIT, T-MAX, Hardtop, Distort, so das reicht dann erstmal, ich glaube ein paar Sachen davon
sind eh schon drauf, ok, so, jetzt können wir es ausprobieren, was ich mache, ich versuche
gerade das hier zu installieren, dass ich meine Services daheim simpel überwachen kann
ohne meine komische Prometheus Grafana Geschichte weiter ausbauen, zumindest, du willst doch
Neo Fetch, ok, auf geht's, wie heißt denn das andere, wie heißt denn diese Alternative
zu Neo Fetch, Screen, nee, Screen 2 oder irgendwie sowas, es gab doch sowas, die das noch fancier
gemacht haben als Neo Fetch, nee, nee, nee, nee, es gibt irgendwas, Screen Fetch, genau,
Screen Fetch meine ich, Screen Fetch, guck mal, für Neo Fetch muss der erstmal irgendwie
30 Milliarden extra Packages installieren, Ghostscript, warum braucht der Ghostscript
dafür, ok, für euch Chat hier, Neo Fetch, bam, Pog, was ich bei Neo Fetch noch nicht
so ganz kapiert habe, für was stehen die einzelnen Farben hier neben, ist das irgendwie
was, wie geil dein Terminal ist oder hat das irgendwas Tieferes zu bedeuten, was ist Wim
ein Text Editor fürs Terminal, hier, da und außerdem supportet der Port Children in Uganda,
away, so Text Editor, kannst du so Dinger hier machen, kannst Text editieren oder Sachen
markieren und Sachen löschen und Wörter löschen und Lull, Lull, keck W, kannst du
unten drunter gehen und irgendwie das gleiche nochmal reinschreiben, oh jetzt hab ich vertippt,
das gleiche nochmal reinschreiben oder das beste Wim Feature aller Zeiten, was wahrscheinlich
kaum einer kennt, Ctrl X und Ctrl A Leute, guck mal Wim kann zählen, A zählt hoch, Ctrl
A und Ctrl X zählt runter, wann man das braucht, ich weiß es nicht so genau aber ab und zu
benutze ich es mal und was auch ein ziemlich praktisches Feature ist von Wim, ist wenn
man zum Beispiel Konfig Dateien hat, sagen wir mal das hier ist meine Konfig Datei, es
gibt jetzt diese Variante hier von der Konfig Datei und was weiß ich, es gibt, die ändert
sich ein bisschen, zumindest wenn man Ctrl Y drückt, nee, Mist ich hab vergessen was
es war, ach das war Ctrl Y, nee dann hab ich's vergessen, man konnte den Kram hier, ach
doch hier Ctrl Y ist es doch, man kann den Kram quasi mit Ctrl Y repeaten lassen, dann
kann man das bis zu der Stelle repeaten lassen, wo man was ändern muss, weiter repeaten und
so, das ist manchmal schneller als Copy Paste, ja was gibt es sonst noch für schöne Lul
123 Klammer auf Pog Test, also was gibt es sonst noch für schöne Wim Shortcuts, wenn
man jetzt zur 2 springen will, kann man einfach machen F2, dann springt man zur 2, dann kann
man sagen Ci Quotes, dann löscht man alles zwischen Quotes und kann das ändern und sowas,
ja gibt es jede Menge Sachen, was man mit Wim machen kann, also Wim ist ziemlich auf
Tastaturbedienung ausgelegt, ach ja und Wim schließt man mit Doppelpunkt Q, alternativ
auch mit XQ wenn man schreiben will oder mit X Ausrufezeichen oder mit Shift ZZ, warum
es 50 Varianten gibt Wim zu schließen, man weiß es nicht, wahrscheinlich ist das so der
Geekwettbewerb, wer weiß mehr Varianten Wim zu schließen als der andere, Alter 4 geht
nicht, Alter 4 geht unter Windows wahrscheinlich mit GWim, weil falls es noch nicht reicht,
habe ich nicht installiert, es gibt auch noch die grafische Variante davon, so aber gut
was auch immer, was wollten wir jetzt eigentlich machen, ach so Docker Stells, was für eine
Docker Version ist dann dabei bei Raspberry Pi, 20.10.5, ich habe keine Ahnung ob das
aktuell ist oder nicht, von wann ist das, 20.10.05 vom März, naja das ist neu genug, was soll
da, was soll da, was soll da großartig sein, abinstall Docker Punkt, wir können auch Snap
installieren Leute, soll ich es mit Snap oder mit Docker machen, nein es geht mit Snap gar
nicht, ich habe einfach nur gebadet gefragt, Moment warum installiert er denn ZF, ach nee
dann probieren wir das mal aus jetzt würde ich sagen, ich muss ja sagen hat mal jemand
von euch die Ehre gehabt was mit Nagios zu machen, so der Klassiker unter dem Monitoring
System, der sieht ja mittlerweile auch besser aus als früher, aber so sah das im Prinzip
20 Jahre lang aus, Nagios läuft bei euch immer noch, ja es hatte teilweise schon echt ein
paar Oldschool Vibes würde man heutzutage sagen, da muss ich sagen das habe ich nie
wirklich verwendet, Products, haben die auch eine Demo, wie das jetzt aussieht mittlerweile,
Demo, Demo, Demo, so viel, ok es sieht immer noch ziemlich ähnlich aus, bloß ein bisschen
moderner, kann man eigentlich mittlerweile hier jetzt die Hosts über das Web Interface
anlegen, das musstest du ja früher über config files machen, mal ganz davon abgesehen
warum ich das mit Nagios eigentlich zeige ist folgendes, ich habe ja so ein Herz für
Nagios, also ich finde Nagios immer noch nice, das mag aber daran liegen, aber auch wenn
ich selbst Nagios schon ganz lange nicht mal verwendet habe, aber ich mag Nagios, das liegt
aber wahrscheinlich daran, weil mein erstes größeres Projekt für das ich zuständig war,
so quasi zu und nach Azubi Zeiten war Nagios, deswegen mag ich Nagios immer noch, auch wenn
ich es wahrscheinlich nicht mal verwenden würde, der Vorteil von Nagios, also was ich
nach wie vor bei Nagios cool finde vom Ansatz her, dass es eigentlich zum größten Teil
aus irgendwelchen Shellscripts besteht, deine Checks und du einfach alles und jeden monitoren
kannst, sofern da irgendwas läuft oder im Zweifelsfall auch nur irgendwie in der Basht
oder irgendwas, also finde ich vom Ansatz her eigentlich cool, aber die config war ein
bisschen pains champ, so mit NAPE, Agent und Dinger was da alles gab, aber ich mag Nagios
immer noch, ja Aladdin ist am Start, so Sorgastells, deswegen nutzt du Kron, naja gut Kron ist
jetzt vielleicht nicht so der allergeilste Monitoring Tool, ich mein ich weiß dass es
Services gibt, die haben Webhooks, da kannst du per Kron und Krol quasi Webhooks an Triggern
und sowas, aber die Sache ist die, ich finde Monitoring das Pult einfacher als Monitoring
das pusht, das hängt ein bisschen von der Umgebung ab natürlich und was man macht,
also was damit gemeint ist, du kannst es ja entweder so einstellen, mal angenommen ich
will jetzt wissen ob ein Server up ist oder down ist, dann kann ich entweder von einem
zentralen Monitoring Server aus abfragen, ne Webseite auf dem Server oder so und gucke
ob das stimmt was zurückkommt oder ich kann es umgedreht machen, der Server meldet alle
60 Sekunden, dass er ok ist und wenn die Meldung aus bleibt geht es halt auf nicht da, also
das gibt so zwei verschiedene Ansätze, es gibt so Pull und Push und Pull hat halt den
großen Vorteil, du brauchst keine Firewall-Freischaltung, mit Push hast du dann oftmals das Problem,
du brauchst dann zwischendrin noch irgendwelche Proxy Server, weil der Server der pushen will
eigentlich nicht zum zentralen Monitoring System darf und sowas, ich finde das eigentlich
simpler wenn Monitoring die Daten pullt anstatt das gepusht wird, deswegen finde ich den Ansatz
von Prometheus auch ganz cool, weil die pullen auch, ja erzähl, was haben sie sich gefragt,
schieß los, das bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, ja Hells Check sei auch, genau sowas in der
Richtung will ich haben, ah ne, ne sowas hier, ne das mein ich nicht, ich wollt bloß sagen
plus lokal, aber eigentlich, ja wie willst du das denn sonst nähen, pull und wie willst
du so Monitoring, Pull, Push, sowas, schieben und ziehen oder was, ich weiß nicht ob schieben
und ziehen die bessere Variante ist als pull und push, hochladen und runterladen, ne, ne
zappix, zappix haben wir auch wie gesagt, wir haben auf der Arbeit ne Kombination aus zappix
so für die klassischen Sachen und Prometheus Grafana für metric kram, ach ja und dann
haben wir noch irgendwie so ne komische Third Party Software, die von außen monitort, das
ist eh was ganz abgedrehtes, da haben sie sich mal irgendwie wieder für tausende Euro
ne Lizenz gekauft, wo sie dann auf drei Rechnern in Deutschland was installiert haben, was
dann über irgendwelche DSL Anschlüsse, Zugriff von außen auf uns, unser System macht und
guckt ob noch alles da ist, das ist so unglaublich bescheuert, dass die dir für Geld ausgegeben
haben, ich hätte denen einfach nen 20 Euro Startgutschein von Hetzner geben können,
wir hätten uns quasi an drei Standorten auf der Welt hätten wir uns vor Ems gemacht
und würden da einfach regelmäßig nen Curl ausführen und alles ist gut, übrigens wenn
ihr euch auch 20 Euro Startgut haben sichern wollt bei Hetzner, macht mal Ausrufezeichen
Hetzner im Chat, da könnt ihr euch noch bis Ende des Jahres einen 20 Euro Cloud Gutscheincode
sichern, Max 21, es sind sogar ein bisschen mehr als 20 Euro, weil die Leute haben gesagt,
das rechnet es irgendwie komisch um mit oder ohne Mehrwertsteuer oder irgendwie Dollar,
Euro oder so, am Ende sind es glaube ich sogar 23, 50 oder sowas, der Überleitung Scott,
ja kennst du PRTG, ja kenn ich, ist aber Windows Only fällt für mich flach, ich weiß, ich
weiß, ja, hatte ich mir vor einer Woche erst eingeguckt, so also, hat der Kusswort schon
geschrieben was sie ihn gefragt haben, deutsche IT Begriffe gar nicht erst angemeldet, hey
ich finds richtig geil, wenn ich beispielsweise aus der Berufsschule oder so von manchen Azubis
irgendwelche Programmieraufgaben sehe, wo dann so drinnen steht, setze variable Zahl
auf 1 und solche Dinge in den Kommentaren, unten drunter steht dann wirklich Wahrzahl
gleich 1 oder sowas, CheckMk2 habe ich mir letztens angeguckt, da habe ich nicht gecheckt,
wenn man das nämlich installiert ist es in der Trial, braucht man irgendwie Lizenzkey
auch für die Free Version oder hat man eine Trial und wenn die ausläuft, dann Decade
sie automatisch zur Free Version, das war auch wieder ein geiler Satz oder, aber ich
glaube ihr versteht was ich meine, sie Decade dann zur Free Version, was, was ist das, was
ist das?
Wirklich?
Gibt es das mittlerweile?
PRTG ist doch Windows Only, das gibt es nicht für Linux, jaja ne, es gibt, es gibt irgendeinen
Client für Linux, wie auch immer man dafür einen Client braucht, es hat ja ein Webinterface
dachte ich, ach hier so, also was haben sie dich gefragt, ob du schon eigene Projekte
gemacht hast, welche Sprachen ich schon kenne, ob ich schon mal mit anderen Leuten zusammen
im Team programmiert habe, wie heißen die Entwicklungsumgebungen in denen ich programmiert
habe, das waren so Fachspieler, und was hast du gesagt?
Also kam da, was hast du gesagt und wie kam das an?
Ein Programmierumgebung natürlich nur Emacs und Lisp, Notepad, genau, man sollte gar nicht
mal so sehr lachen über so die richtig krassen Wim-Hacker-Mans, viele der Competitive Programmer,
ja es gibt Competitive Programming, das war mir auch nicht klar, bis vor einer Weile,
die Competitive Programmer, die verwenden zum größten Teil die Kombination Wim und C++,
was ich persönlich für Alltagsprojekte absolut Paynes-Champ finden würde, ist für Geschwindigkeit
anscheinend eines der besten Sachen, also sowohl Entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit als auch
letztendlich Ausführungsgeschwindigkeit, weil die Ausführungsgeschwindigkeit nicht
so wild ist, aber anscheinend Wim plus C++, gleich krass ist der Entwicklungsspeed für
so Testaufgaben, Challenges aller Zeiten.
Jaja, aber wie geht das, wie kriege ich mein Checkmk zu der Free-Version?
Ich hab das im Docker installiert letztens und da hat er mir gesagt, das ist eine Trial,
obwohl ich die Free-Version angeblich installiert hab, als eine Trial, die in 29 Tagen ausläuft.
Ja, es gibt Schlimmeres, ich mein, besser, zum Beispiel, ich mein besser als die Leute,
die teilweise noch auf dem Papier programmieren müssten, ihr könnt, ihr könnt sich vorstellen,
bei mir ist die Ausbildung zwar schon ein bisschen her, aber jetzt so lange auch noch
nicht her, wir sollten in der Arbeit, für Programmieren, allen Ernstes, C auf dem Papier
programmieren.
Und er hat tatsächlich auch Syntaxfehler bewertet, der größte Stumpfsinn aller Zeiten, Syntaxfehler
beim auf dem Papier programmieren, wo sind wir, 1970, wo man noch irgendwelche Hexwerte
automatisch wo reinschreiben muss?
Ja, da hab ich aber, ich hab dann die Video letztens zugeguckt, hab ich nicht so ganz
gecheckt, was das sein soll, ist das die Funktion, ist das der Versuch, Visual Studio Code auf
Java Basis Konkurrenz zu machen oder, das hab ich nicht verstanden.
Ja, bei der IHK-Prüfung, ja, gut, da gibt's ja eh nur Papier, das ist Pain's Jam, das
ist doch so realitätsfern.
HTML Aufbau, das ist so realitätsfern, ich weiß gar nicht, wie zurückgeblieben die eigentlich
überall sind.
Was geht Chat lesen gerade, Gubel, Gubelte, G, Prime Gaming, Dankeschön, Massive Sub,
da gibt's einige, die sind richtig krass.
Sündags Highlighting mit dem Textmarker, ja, das ist auch mal was, das ist auch mal, so
also wollen wir mal weitermachen, alle den Kram jetzt, okay, also, wir wollen, wir wollen
Dings hier ausprobieren, Uptime, Uptime Gatchibus, okay, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten,
haben die, haben die Docker-Container, hier, Volume, Quatsch, brauchen wir alles nett,
auch kein Volume, einfach, einfach draufhauen und gut ist, ähm, da soll ein Ordner anlegen
und gut ist, mkdir, keqb, bester Ordner, Docker Run, zack, Permission Denied, bam, warum,
achso, weil ich nicht in der Docker-Gruppe drin bin, ha, warum bin ich nicht in der
Docker-Gruppe drin, ne, warte mal, wo, wo war das, wo war das, Groups, ich mein, man
könnte User-Mods oder sowas verwenden, aber das ist viel cooler, wenn man das, wenn man,
wenn man das, ähm, wie die richtigen Hacker-Mans macht mit Text-Dateien editieren, so, viel,
viel besser, nein, nein, nein, so, so, das ist das, the way, so geht das, so, zack, funktioniert,
ich wusste, ihr braucht irgendwelche komischen Kommandos und müsst euch Parametern merken,
ich brauch vim und einfach etc passwd, dazu kann ich nur sagen, easy, so, download complete,
dann mach hinne, iExtracting, Nano, ne, Nano ist Pains-Champ, Nano ist richtig Pains-Champ,
ne, wozu, ich starte einen Container, was, es gibt mittlerweile Docker-Compose V2, ja,
was ist der Unterschied von V2 zu V1, oder seit wann gibt es denn V2, ja, ach, die haben
das jetzt eingebaut, in Docker direkt, ah, big brain, das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch,
wenn das eingebaut ist, da muss man das nicht mal zusätzlich installieren, hat er das jetzt,
Docker-PS, bam, läuft, Port 3001, net-stat, guck mal, ob das auch wirklich stimmt, nicht
dass der instubated, dass es gar nicht läuft, Port 3001, tatsächlich, es läuft, so, was
haben wir noch mal für eine IP, oh, leak, Leute, leak, nicht einloggen, so, dann probieren
wir das mal aus, uptime-kuma, ach ne, sack, 3001, bam, manchmal ist Firefox-Pains-Champ,
dass der mitdenkt, kein F-Config, ich weiß gar nicht, doch F-Config ist noch drauf, ja,
da sind wir, uptime-kuma, ich finde den Namen immer noch ein bisschen unglücklich, warum
ist der Stream nicht von Hetzer gesponsert, weil wir nichts mit Hetzer machen, ok, Benutzername,
Namen, Passwort, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, bam, create, wie sie mir wieder
sagen wollen, was ich für Passwörter machen soll, warum ich das nicht mit Hetzer mache,
warum sollte ich was für mein internes Monitoring bei Hetzer in die Cloud stellen, also, man
muss ja nicht übertreiben, ich meine, ich könnte, ich könnte das auf Hetzer machen
und dann ein VPN zu mir ins interne Netzwerk aufbauen, dass es von außen nach innen monitoren
kann, und wenn mal irgendjemand krassen Hacker-Man auf meinem Server macht, ist er auch direkt
bei mir im Heimnetzwerk drin, sehr gute Idee.
WhiteStrikes will wieder seinen WIP-Status debaten, ich sehe es schon, schon mal Telegraph
angesehen, ja, habe ich, ich habe sogar die komplette Kombination, äh, Dings, wie heißt
das, Chronograph, Telegraph und InfluxDB war das glaube ich mir angeguckt, das ist im Prinzip
relativ vergleichbar zur Prometheus Grafana Mischung, aber für meine Einsatzzwecke einfach
zu, also für den Einsatzzweck nicht gedacht und dann auch noch zu umständlich für die
paar Sachen.
Ach du hast weiter oben geschrieben, zeig mal, wo ist er, was, achso als Idees hast du gesagt
Piedscharm, aber gut, ich mein, als Azubi, ich finde schon mal gut, dass man das überhaupt
kennt, Eclipse, Seven TV verwende ich, will ich nicht verwenden, da sind sehr fragwürdige
Emails drin, ja Antworten ganz gut angekommen, ja das ist nice, tja ich habe einige Videos
noch ausstehen, wofür brauchst du das Monitoring, für mein eigenes Zeug, ich will zum Beispiel
gucken, ob der Raspberry Pi für die Kamera an der Tür noch oben ist und was weiß ich,
ob mein MQTT Server da ist, ob Zertifikat ablaufen oder sonst was, also nichts großartiges.
Noch weiter oben, noch größerer Tweet, Achtung jetzt muss man gucken, wo ist er, ach hier
ok, er hat geantwortet, er hat schon kleine Projekte gemacht, Discordbot, Passwort Prüfer,
was ist denn ein Passwort Prüfer, der vielleicht auf seinem Passwort schon mal geleakt, achso,
ach du meinst hier mit, äh, äh, Dings, und Punkt, ne wie heißt das, have I been pwned,
sonst was, DB, ne.
Als Sprachen habe ich mir Java und Python schon angeguckt, im Team habe ich nicht Bock
auf eine Möglichkeit dazu, allerdings habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich nicht, ja das ist
immer eine gute Antwort, so nach dem Motto eigentlich sagen, ich bin der geilste auf
der Welt, aber dann immer noch ein bisschen runterspielen, aber eigentlich fühle ich
mich wie der letzte Noob, ja, ok next, hoffentlich gibt es ein Dark 7, damit stehen und fällen
das ganze, wir lassen jetzt einfach mal den Firefox so ein super secure Standard Passwort
generieren, create, update, ok, das ist, ok, die Installation war easy, Docker Container
gestartet, fertig aus, in was ist denn das programmiert, uptime, gachigasm, server, ah
das sieht so nach, nach Javascript Kram aus, Prometheus Client, ach kann man da mit eine
Prometheus Sachen von abfragen, oder wie, oder was, ne, wahrscheinlich, wieviel Ram
das braucht, oh, hart am Limit, das ist ja schon, das schafft er nicht, null byte von
null byte, gut Limit hat er ja nicht, aber das braucht so gut wie nix gerade, aber wenn
er ein paar Checks laufen hat, wird es wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen, wird es wahrscheinlich
schon ein bisschen mehr haben gleich, gab es nicht auch sowas wie Docker Top oder C Top
oder irgendwie sowas, up search, C Top, C Top Github, war das nicht sowas, das da meine
ich, C Top gab es da auch noch, ist das überhaupt das gleiche Tool, 076, ne, das ist nicht das
gleiche, das ist irgendein anderes Tool was auch so heißt, das ist natürlich wieder Sixthead
oh, das ist natürlich was, Docker, Docker Tool in Docker laufen lassen, das ist Big
Brain Leute, Docker Tool in Docker selbst, jawoll, das muss sein, exquisite, exquisite,
oh ne, gibt es nicht für Arm V7, Anzeige ist raus, ne, gibt es nicht für Arm V7, was
ist denn das hier, was soll das denn, warum gibt es das nicht für Arm, gibt es doch,
das ist doch eh, das ist doch eh Go Stells, oder, ja, also Copy Link, WeGet, WeGets, WeGets,
Punkt Slash C Top, ach ne, chmod plus x, C Top, zack, schauen wir mal, zack, da sind wir
doch keine Container da, doch, da ist er doch, ja, da wissen wir, da wissen wir, dass wir
nix wissen, weil der irgendwie ganz schön wenig, muss ich das mal, ob ich das jetzt
als Root starte oder nicht, ist doch eigentlich egal, oder, ne, das Ding verbraucht so gut
für nichts im Endeffekt, gut, aber dann gucken wir uns, gucken wir uns den ganzen Kram doch
mal an, wenn wir das Ding jetzt hier laufen lassen, hast du gute Tipps für den Einstieg
in Smart Home, ja, hab ich, und, hab ich den Chat zugemacht, ne, ich ziehe jetzt erstmal
in meine erste eigene Wohnung und würde gerne damit, also gut, dann vermute ich auch mal,
dass das nicht das allergrößte ist, das ist tatsächlich sogar ganz praktisch, weil,
dann hast du wahrscheinlich von deiner Kiste, wo dein Home Assistant oder dein Smart Home
Zeug läuft, auch direkt Connection zu allen Geräten, ja, also das beste ist, Quatsch,
nicht den Heizchamp, der Heizchamp brauchst du nicht, das beste ist, du suchst dir irgendwas
raus, was dir auf den Keks geht, wo du auch wirklich einen Mehrwert draus hast, es gibt
viele Leute, die fangen mit RGB Beleuchtung an, das finde ich ist eines der unsinnigsten
Sachen, mit der man anfangen kann, finde ich, finde ich nicht gut, weil die meisten Leute
brauchen ja keine RGB Beleuchtung, man kann sich vielleicht überlegen, ob man nicht irgendwelche
dimmbaren Lichter irgendwo einbaut, wenn einem das nervt, aber normalerweise hat man an den
wenigsten Stellen wirklich Bedarf für RGB, für RGB Beleuchtung, aber ich würde irgendwas
nehmen, was dich wirklich nervt, von der Heizungssteuerung bis zu deiner Waage im Bad, wo du irgendeinen
schönen Graph draus machen kannst, bis zu Fenster und Türsensoren, die ich persönlich
relativ praktisch finde, dass man weiß, ok, ich hab vergessen das Fenster im Bad zu zu
machen, wenn ich gerade aus der Wohnung gehe, da gibt es jede Menge Sachen, deswegen würde
ich mir erstmal überlegen, was ist das, was mich persönlich nervt, was ich am liebsten
automatisieren möchte, weil dann hast du auch gleich einen sinnvollen Anwendungsfall,
weil sonst läuft es darauf raus, dass du dir ziemlich Dinge kaufst, die du einfach nur
zu haben, um sie zu haben, was dann relativ sinnlos ist, das erinnert mich ein bisschen
an die Leute, die bei reddit self-hosted immer ihre krassen Self-hosted Dashboards haben
und 90% davon brauchen sie nicht, beziehungsweise sind quasi Software, um andere Software,
die da ist, dann anzuzeigen, was weiß ich, die Leute sagen dann, boah, ich bin jetzt
auch ein krasses Self-Hoster, posten dann irgendwie was, posten von ihrem Dashboard, posten sie
ihre Nextcloud Instance, ihr Portainer, ihr Wiki und ihr Dashboard-Container, ihren Grafana-Container,
also ich hab quasi 80% administrative Container zu 20% Container, die sie benutzen, was im
Prinzip darauf hindeut, dass sie das eigentlich gar nicht bräuchten, deswegen find's immer
sinnvoll, wenn man mit was anfängt, wo man einen eigenen persönlichen Anwendungsfall
hat, der einem das Leben leichter machen würde.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, warum man Null hat, wahrscheinlich ist das so gering im Verbrauch.
Ja, falls du auf smarte Home-Geschichten mit Voice Assistant stehst, da kannst du dir das
auch angucken, klar, für viele ist das wohl so ein richtig krasser Selling-Point, wo sie
sagen, oh cool, ich will sagen können, hier, Alexa, wann kommt als nächstes die Müllabfuhr,
das ist was, was mich persönlich jetzt nicht sonderlich schockt, ich hab noch nicht mal
einen Voice Assistant irgendwo.
Ja, so was, genau so was meine ich, das ist richtig gut, weil es einem das Leben leichter
macht.
Und zum Beispiel, ich weiß ja nicht, wie es in deiner Wohnung aussieht, es gibt ja
bestimmt nur noch die einen oder anderen Wohnungen, die dann im Keller sowas haben, gerade wenn
es die erste Wohnung ist, ein bisschen kleiner ist, ein bisschen billiger ist, die dann irgendwie
so gemeinsam Waschraum im Keller haben oder irgendwie sowas, da wäre es natürlich cool,
falls du da irgendwie dann sogar einen Rüttelsensor dahinter kleben könntest, sodass du es machen
darfst und dann kriegst du mit, wenn im Keller deine Wäsche fertig ist oder so, oder eine
Steckdose dazwischen stecken, da kannst du...
Waschkeller Setup, ja, das ist richtig cool, das macht einem wirklich das Leben einfacher.
Ja, also ich find's ja geil, ich bin jetzt mittlerweile bei mir daheim ja schon mit 10
Gigabit Netzwerk mittlerweile schon seit ein paar Jahren im 10 Gigabit Bereich angekommen
und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, also die riesen Vorteile für mich haben sich da jetzt
noch nicht ausgespielt, was cool ist, von der SSD im Nass ordentlich schnell was zu kopieren,
das mache ich aber eh nur alle Schaltjahre, mal da größere Sachen kopieren.
Und ansonsten habe ich es halt, weil es eigentlich günstig genug ist, oder es ist so günstig
mittlerweile 10 Gigabit Netzwerk daheim, gerade wenn man irgendwas neues baut, warum sollte
man das nicht machen?
Also es ist mittlerweile eigentlich gar keine Frage mehr, finde ich.
Es spricht nichts dagegen, aber 100G würde ich mir tatsächlich überlegen.
Also das meiste, also wenn du wirklich die günstigste und stromsparendste Variante haben
willst, dann SFP plus, oftmals ist es aber halt so ein Ding, wenn man durch die Wand
muss und da keine Leerrohre liegen hat, Glasfaser hat halt kaum einer im Haus verlegt und Direct
Attached Kupferkabel kriegst du vielleicht hin von einem Stockwerk ins andere, aber nicht
einmal quer durchs Haus.
Also ich würde dort wo es in der Nähe ist, immer SFP plus Direct Attached Kabel nehmen,
das ist billig und da ist sowohl die Switche billiger, als auch die Netzwerkkarten billiger,
ansonsten halt ein bisschen teurer und komfortabel.
Ich würde heute trotzdem 10G nehmen, weil 10G nicht mal nennenswert teurer ist, also
ich würde, das stimmt nicht was ich sage, ich würde nicht alles auf 10G machen, ich
sage nur sich jetzt was zu kaufen, was nicht auch 10G fähig ist wäre blöd, also zum Beispiel
sich einen Switch zu kaufen mit 2 bis 10 10G Interfaces und dann irgendwie nochmal X1G,
das finde ich ist sinnvoll.
Ich würde mir keinen 24 Port 10G Switch kaufen, weil die sind natürlich teurer, aber ein
2 Port, also 2 mal 10G und 24 fach oder was auch immer, 12 fach, 24 fach, 1G das finde
ich ist das optimale und es ist vom Preis her eigentlich gar keine Ausrede das wegzulassen
mittlerweile.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns einfach mal den Kram hier an.
Da sind wir ja stehen geblieben, das ist ja eigentlich die Geschichte die ich machen wollte.
Boah, haben wir ein Darkseam?
Darkseam läuft Settings?
Yes, viel besser, viel besser, jetzt bin ich wirklich nicht mehr so geplendet, so ist das
doch gleich netter oder?
So ist das doch gleich richtig, Zeitzone League, oh fack, ok, Hardbar, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
Hardbar, ja, die haben mittlerweile 10G Nasskisten, du kannst einfach, wenn das eine Kiste ist,
du kannst einfach eine 10G Karte PCI Express reinbauen, kostet nichts, auf Ebay, auf Ebay
30 Euro, ist dann zwar nicht die neueste Karte aber das macht ja nichts, PCI Express, zack,
ok, so wo sind wir stehen geblieben, also was können wir jetzt hier schönes machen, Dashboard,
Up, Down, Status, das ist ja schrecklich, go to death, aha, aha, ich weiß was er verkackt
hat, er hat das, er hat den, den, den, den Bodytag nicht getheamed, sondern er hat die
View-App getheamed, das ist ein Fehler, den hab ich auch am Anfang öfters gemacht, ja
gut, man siehts jetzt hier nicht, nicht wirklich, guck eigentlich, eigentlich müsstest du,
ne, das hier hat er getheamed, das hier, aber eigentlich müsste er seinen Bodytag themen
auf Dark Mode, dann hast du nämlich nicht das Problem, dass beim Refresh kurzes weiß
flackert, da muss ich mal was fixen, ja probier es mal aus, ob ich nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist
erzählt habe, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich das gleiche Problem auch schon öfters
hatte und die Lösung war den Bodytag zu themen anstatt den App, was bisschen eklig war aber
gut, zumindest hab ich es hinbekommen und ich glaube damals hab ich das rausgekriegt
einfach durch, was sonst, Stack Overflow, ja, wie heißt die Playlist, die läuft, das
ist irgendwie so Weihnachtsmusik, Nintendo Weihnachtsmusik, 70 Minuten Winter Holiday
Nintendo Music, so, also probieren wir die ganzen Kram doch mal aus, was können wir
jetzt hier schönes machen, Add Monitor, gut, aktuell ist nichts ab und nichts dauernd ist
ja auch noch nichts drinne, welchen 10 Gigabit Switch kann man sich günstig holen, ich hatte
nur 170 Euro Netgear, ich würde mir, wenn es um günstige 10G-Switch geht, ist das beste,
was du holen kannst, die Dinger von Mikrotik, hast du Erfahrungen mit Gaming unter Popo
CS, nein, Quatsch, das ist der falsche, ja, CSS3, ja, nimm den, da kannst du nichts mit
falsch machen, 24 Ports, 1G, 2 Ports, SFP+, und ansonsten die anderen, zum Beispiel der,
der auch gerade einer im Chat postet, ah ja, der ist auch gut, den habe ich auch hier, das
sind 4 10G-Ports, auch relativ günstig, oder wo ist der 309, das ist ein Router, Router-Switch,
dazu kann ich nichts sagen, du hast sogar 8, ok, hier kriegst du sogar 8, aber ich glaube
der beste Switch für daheim, ich glaube der beste Switch für daheim ist tatsächlich
nach wie vor der hier, weil du kriegst 10G, du kriegst 10G-Ports und 24 1G-Ports, wenn
du ein bisschen mehr Optionen haben willst, dann holst du dir den da, das ist quasi einmal
mit den Basic-Varianten Switch OS und einmal komplett mit Router OS drauf, also hier kannst
du wirklich den abgedrehtesten Scheiß mit machen, wobei die CPU nicht dafür ausgelegt
ist jetzt wahnsinnig große Routing-Action zu machen, aber für daheim reicht das, aber
wenn du einfach nur einen Switch haben willst mit WLAN-Support, dann nimmste das, und wenn
du wirklich abgedrehte Sachen machen willst wie von irgendwelche Firewall-Regeln oder
was weiß ich, von DHCP-Server bis DNS bis alles mögliche VPN, dann nimmste den, und
ansonsten nimmste den, der ist glaube ich lüfterlos, ich glaube der hat gar keinen
Lüfter, ich glaube der ist lüfterlos, du kannst einen Lüfter einmal, aber ich glaube
der ist standardmäßig lüfterlos, ich hab den nicht, muss ich dazu sagen, ich hab, ich
hab den hier, Moment welchen hab ich hier oben stehen, ich hab hier oben ein CSS 610
stehen, CSS 610, der ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht, den kannst du auch nehmen, da kriegst
du 2 SFP plus Ports und 8, 8 Gigabit Ports, und der ist lüfterlos, den hab ich hier neben
auf dem Basteltisch stehen, also MikroTik hat für alle was, guck mal 99 Euro, da kannst
du doch nichts sagen, 99 Euro, 2 10G Ports und 8 Gigabit Ports, CSS, und man muss sagen
die Benamung bei MikroTik macht sogar irgendwie Sinn, das ist ein Cloud Switch, weil es gibt
auch noch einen Cloud Router Switch, warum auch immer, bescheuert, so das ist der Typname,
das bedeutet du hast 8 Gigabit Ports und 2 SFP plus Ports und ja was auch immer in ist,
PoE in wahrscheinlich, hat das PoE, PoE in, genau, also die Benamung bei denen macht sogar
Sinn, so jetzt kommen wir mal zu der eigentlichen Geschichte, was ich die ganze Zeit schon ausprümeln
will, ja also das würde ich dir als Tipp geben, guck dir das mal an, so also jetzt adden wir
mal ein paar Überwachungsgeschichten, so fangen wir mal an, Add Monitor, was haben wir denn
hier zur Auswahl, keine Ahnung, Captain Peng, weiß ich nicht, der hier hat Strom vorne,
also wir können überwachen, HTTP, TCP Port, Ping, HTTP Keyword, was auch immer, was ist
der Unterschied da dazwischen, ah, der guckt der Response, ob irgendwie im Text was vorkommt,
wir können DNS Anfragen checken, ob die funktionieren oder wir haben Webhooks vermute ich mal, sowas
in der Richtung und wir können natürlich auch Steam Game Server checken, was auch immer,
das brauch ich nicht, so Ping, so machen wir mal hier Friendly Name, DoorCamp Pie zum Beispiel,
so Hausname, ich tja, ich glaub das, werden wir jetzt gleich sehen, ob es richtig ist,
so Retries, ja auf jeden Fall drei Retries, einmal in der Minute checken, einmal in der
Minute retryen, was Upside Down, ah, wenn er Down ist wird er als Up angezeigt, wenn
er Up ist wird er als Down angezeigt, nee das brauchen wir nicht, Tags lassen wir erstmal
weg, Setup Notifications, was kann der denn, guck mal Discord, ich kann mich sogar im Discord
benachrichtigen lassen, wenn meine Kamera am Tor kaputt geht, aber das lassen wir erstmal
weg, ok, Ping, hoffentlich hab ich die IP richtig eingestellt, BAM, NA, Pending, Destination
Unreachable, ok, die IP ist falsch, sollte das nicht eigentlich rot werden, warum ist
es auf Pending, wenn Destination Unreachable ist, ah, wahrscheinlich weil es initial einmal
verkehrt sein, weil es einmal funktioniert haben muss, dass es dringend, ok, das ist
auf jeden Fall die falsche IP, war es 49, ich weiß es aus dem Kopf gar nicht was die
IP von meiner Kamera ist, müsste ich mal nachgucken, ach wegen Retry, genau, save, ja jetzt wartet
der mit dem retry in einer Minute, also ich hoffe mal es ist jetzt, ich ping das Ding jetzt
einfach mal selbst, ist das hier richtig, ok ich muss mal kurz in meinen Switch gucken,
ok mal in den DHCP Sauber gucken, ich weiß es nicht, was das Ding für eine IP hat, DHCP
Sauber liest es, ah, falsches Netz, 6049 ist es, 6049, alles klar, ok, tja, kaum macht
man es richtig, dann geht es auch, dann ändern wir das mal, 6049, save, jetzt ist es auch
grün, guckt, jetzt einer ab, DNS, brauchen wir nicht, DNS Overrated, Gebated, Outdated,
ich glaube das Ding hat sogar einen DNS Eintrag, aber benutze ich nie, so, jetzt sieht man das
Ding ist ab und man kann sich jetzt sogar das Statistik ab, das ist ja nice, das ist ja
nice, ja, klar, woher können wir eigentlich mal drin lassen, guck, hier sieht man hier
was nicht da, jetzt ist es da, das ist ab, ping 6 Millisekunden, dafür ein WLAN Gerät
ist doch ok, wie heißt die Software, Uptime Kuma, hier Status Page, nothing to see, edit,
monitor, aha, was, hä, ah, da muss man die einfach hinzufügen, ok, ja und jetzt hat
man eine Status Page, ich meine, viel simpler geht die Übersicht doch nicht, oder sehe
ich jetzt sofort, wenn irgendwas down ist, das sollte dann bald mal auf nahezu 100% gehen,
wenn er jetzt ein paar mal gecheckt hat und hier sehe ich auch die Übersicht, das ist
praktisch, so, jetzt probieren wir mal ein bisschen was komplizierteres, wir versuchen
mal meinen MQTT Server, da bin ich nämlich auch drauf angewiesen, dass der funktioniert,
also add monitor, was haben wir denn so, auch der TCP Port müsste das jetzt sein, TCP Port
friendly name, huge chat, hostname, ich glaube, und ich glaube es ist, 1883 ist der MQTT Port,
save, hey, funktioniert, bam, nice, so, ändern wir das mal, ok, das finde ich wirklich schick,
genau nach so was simplem habe ich gesucht, da kannst du da eigentlich gar nicht allzu
viel falsch machen, da kommen jetzt einfach die ganzen Sachen rein, die mal Probleme machen
und dann weiß ich direkt, was ist, ja, zum Beispiel die Kamera hinten in dem Zimmer,
wo der Katzenklo steht, fragt mich nicht, warum ich eine Kamera über dem Katzenklo
habe, aber, so, das müsste das hier sein.
Ja, gut, nice, add monitor, Katze, Kamera, ah nee, nicht HTTP, ping, ping, Katze Kamera,
ja, 3 retry, ich mache immer 3 retry, das klingt doch ganz sinnig, Katze Kamera ist da, nice,
das finde ich gut, also ich muss sagen, das überzeugt mich, das Ding, das ist simpel,
die Frage ist jetzt, wo speichert der das denn überhaupt drinne, ist das, was ist da
im Hintergrund, ist das lokal, hat der irgendwie SQLite oder Export, nee, das sind nur Notifications,
was ist wenn die, wo speichert die Historie drin, ist das bestimmt irgendwie SQLite oder
so, können wir mal gucken, ja, keckw, hier haben wir es drinne gestartet, nee, wie ging
das, docker enter, oh je, ganz docker pros, wie ging das nochmal, docker attach, was attach,
und dann sowas, wie ging das, docker attach, attach und dann, oh, boah, das wollte ich
nicht, nein, jetzt, jetzt habe ich es ausgeschaltet, keckw, ach, exec bash drinne, stimmt, ja, ja,
docker exec, stimmt, aber war das früher nicht mal docker enter, ich benutze den gerade schon
eine ganze weile, ich blick da nicht durch, das ändert sich zu viel, das war doch früher
docker enter, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass das früher docker enter war, na gut und
jetzt sage ich hier bin bash, falls die eine haben, tatsächlich, bam, so, app und ich sehe
dort eine, db, kuma db, nee, das ist, das ist was anderes, das, ach, Moment, das sind
gar nicht die dinger, data, ach, hier, kuma db, das da, ok, und wie kriege ich jetzt raus,
ob das eine sqlite datenbank ist, ey, obvious, obvious, das muss, das muss eine sqlite datenbank
sein, oder, was sagt ihr, das, also vor allem das hier, finde ich, sieht sehr nach sqlite
aus, obvious sqlite, mach pfeile, habe ich doch probiert, geht nicht, ist nicht drauf,
aber wir können was installieren, lull, was muss man für pfeile installieren, ich meine,
oh, cortis, tja, ich will das nicht updaten, wie scrollt man in den terminal, shift, bild,
hoch, bild, runter, achso, das ist jetzt tmax, ja, in tmax, je nachdem, wie du es eingestellt
hast, auch, aber in tmax machst du ctrl b und bild, hoch, bild, runter, im normalen terminal,
im normalen terminal scrollst du mit shift, bild, hoch, bild, runter, normalerweise würdest
du das jetzt auch sehen, äh, tja, ich hab keine ahnung, wo, debian install file, kein
shimmer, ich würde jetzt auch getippt, dass es co-utils ist, ach, kein shimmer, wir haben
sogar file utils, file utils, ach, kein shimmer, wie das funktioniert, aber ich vermute mal,
dass es eine sqlite ist, ich mein, ich kann das doch bestimmt, gibt es so was wie dockercp,
app, data, kuma, db, ah, yes, da sind wir doch, so, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, welches,
welches paket, ok, welches fucking paket muss ich installieren, damit ich file kriege, file,
wie gibt es das, wie viel installiere ich dann, das file package, nee, nee, nee, nee,
so einfach ist es net, das gab es ja nicht, ja wie, tatsächlich, hab ich das nicht eben
schon ausprobiert, monkaS, ach, dann, das ist übrigens ein bug, äh, wenn du docker
auf massberry pi installierst, oder was heißt, ein bug, der, der macht dann immer so komische
scanlinux images und labert dann so dummes zeug, das kann man deinstallieren, da muss
man gar nichts, ähm, da muss man irgendeinen package deinstallieren, was er bei docker
automatisch mitinstalliert, ähm, das war, du musst, das ist alles schwachsinn, was
die hier schreiben, alles blödsinn, man muss irgendeinen package deinstallieren, was der
sinnloserweise bei docker mitinstalliert, need restart, genau, das musst du machen, dann
ist der kram nämlich weg, das ist irgendeine komische kombination aus docker und raspberry
pi os und was auch immer die da treiben, wenn du needs restart deinstallierst, dann, da
macht er nicht mehr so komische dinge, so, file, kuma db, sqlite database, alles klar,
ok, es ist sqlite drunter, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, ja, ähm, das heißt, das zu backupen
ist auch total einfach, im prinzip einfach das komplette verzeichnis exportieren oder
irgendwo hinschieben und fertig, so was kann man sonst noch für dinger machen, wie testet
man jetzt ob zertifikate auslaufen, das habe ich nämlich auf github gelesen, dass das geht,
das geht erst seit der letzten version, ich hab das, ihr habt das nämlich, ich hab nämlich
vorher schon mal shithub geguckt und die haben erst am 23 oktober die möglichkeit geedet,
dass man zertifikat datum checken kann und die große preisfrage ist, wie mach ich das
jetzt, den eigenen zertifikat check gibt es nicht, also muss ich wahrscheinlich sagen https,
kann man das hier irgendwie ankreuzen, tags, ach ignore errors, wahrscheinlich macht er
das standardmäßig oder, wenn ich sage ignore dann macht das nicht und standardmäßig macht
das wahrscheinlich, das heißt ich bräuchte zum testen meine seite wo das zertifikat
ausläuft, wie hieß diese ssl, es gibt so eine richtig geile ssl testseite, die eigentlich
zertifikate für jeden nur erdenklichen fehlerfall haben, wie hieß das ding nochmal, ssl, was
ist ssl labs, nee, es gab so eine richtig geile seite, die quasi jeden nur erdenkliche
zertifikate hatten, laufen bald aus, ist kaputt, bad ssl, das meine ich, genau, genau das meine
ich, expire, expired, genau, haben die auch, haben die auch was läuft aus, chat wieder
richtig to the way, haben die auch sowas wie läuft bald aus oder so, aber machen wir mal
hier einen check drauf, add new monitor, bam, wow, down, certificate has expired, wie bräuchte
ich bräuchte eigentlich mal was was in einem tag oder in einer woche oder so abläuft,
mal gucken was der da macht, so expire soon, ssl expire soon, was, quals, he, debated
kram hier, that expire soon, da gehts doch bestimmt, da gehts doch bestimmt, kennt jemand
eine seite wo ssl bald abläuft, wann läuft google ab, wahrscheinlich in drei jahren
oder so, ah ne, am 24. januar, ok, es wird doch irgendeine seite geben, wo, wo ist ssl,
ne bad ssl, da gibt es keine, also da habe ich keine gefunden, die bald auslaufen, sondern
nur eins was schon expired ist, bräuchte irgendwas was in den nächsten tagen abläuft
um zu checken was es macht im vorfälle, tja, bräuchte mir eine seite mit einem zertifikat
was bald ausläuft, da fällt mir jetzt keiner ein, vielleicht, kannst du doch, ich könnte
eins generieren, aber das ist da nicht gültig, welche seite, da müssen wir mal google befragen,
nein du kannst leider nicht einstellen wann er warnt, der warnt aktuell, es gibt einen
feature request, das habe ich gefunden, es gibt einen feature request, der sagt man soll
das konfigurierbar machen, ja du kannst dir mit let's encrypt eins ausstellen, du kannst
dir doch mit let's encrypt keins ausstellen, was bloß zwei tage gilt, oder, das gilt doch
immer drei monate, so, es gibt einen feature request, dass du das einstellen kannst, aktuell
macht er das hardcoded, ein tag, hier, der macht das irgendwie ein tag, sieben tage,
vierzehn tage oder so, facebook, wollen wir mal gucken was facebook für ein zertifikat
hat, wann die auslaufen, ach, guck mal da, aber ob das reicht, dass es triggert, weiß
ich nicht, müssen wir mal ausprobieren, also add facebook, nee, das läuft nicht früh
genug, das dauert noch zu lang, das dauert noch zu lang, ach hier, zertifikat, 7 days,
ja ich glaube der warnt erst wenn es kleiner als sieben tage ist, also wir brauchen, wir
brauchen irgendeine zeite, am besten was wo es heute ausläuft, am besten was wo es
heute ausläuft, ok, let's encrypt, die hatten doch so eine, stell doch das datum auf dem
raspberry pi um, oh, das ist eine gute idee, da wäre ich jetzt gar nicht drauf gekommen,
das ist eine gute idee, mal gucken ob das funktioniert, mal gucken ob es das checkt, wir stellen,
wir stellen es einfach richtig feifett, wir stellen, wow, nee, wir stellen das einfach
um, docker, stopp, so, jetzt muss ich dem erstmal beibringen, dass der kein time sync
mehr macht, time, nee, time date ctl, ntp, ach du karte, wie stoppt man das jetzt nochmal,
set, set ntp, balls, so, ntp aus, so, date minus s, boah das kann ich aus dem kopf immer
nicht setzen, wobei wir können auch einfach pi, konfig, nee, pi konfig, sp konfig, system
options, nee, wo ist date time, ob das geht da gar nicht oder, time zone kannst du setzen,
da ist es date minus s, ich glaube dem chat einfach mal hier jetzt, tatsächlich, so, ja
passt so, und wir wollen jetzt, das läuft aus, also 6 da, 12 Uhr vorwärts haben, jawoll,
so, docker, start, uptime, gotchi, gib ihm, hallo, wo ist der Rest, ah das braucht ein
bisschen zum starten, ok, ok, ich hab nix gesagt, expire two days, das ist ein bisschen
knapp, wenn der da jetzt noch nicht mal einen warning anzeigt, wenn der nicht mal einen
warning anzeigt dafür, bei zwei tagen, das ist doch ziemlich blöde oder, ok, dann machen
wir das jetzt noch mal eins weiter, ok, ich muss es nochmal stoppen und nochmal starten,
stopp, stopp, ach der versendet eine Benachrichtigung, aber das ist doof, 7000 Zuschauer Battlefield,
ja, das wundert mich nicht, ok, das ist dumm, das ist dumm, warum macht es jetzt hier keine
Anzeige, gleich mal Pullrequest eröffnen, also ne Anzeige im Dashboard, dass es bald
ausläuft, sollte der schon machen, so den können wir wieder löschen, den brauchen
wir nicht, ja das ist Pains Champ, ich will keine Notifications haben, ich will ne Anzeige
haben, das könnte dann gelb werden oder so, wahrscheinlich hat der bloß Up oder Down,
aber der dürfte mir gerne einen Warning anzeigen, wenn das unter einem Tag ist, wie kann ich
jetzt hier was hinzufügen, ah hier, Facebook, ist auch ein Request drin, dass das in der
GUI angezeigt wird, ja, da machen wir nochmal ein Feature Request, äh, kein Feature, da
machen wir nochmal ein Pullrequest würde ich sagen, mal ganz nach vorne abgehen, ich
hab keine Ahnung wie das Projekt funktioniert, also ich kann jetzt kein Pullrequest aus dem
Ärmel schütteln, weil ich keinen Schimmer hab, wie sind das funktioniert, aber ich
find schonmal gut, dass das ein Vue.js Dashboard ist, da blick ich wenigstens halbwegs durch,
hier Public, wo ist denn das Frontend, wo ist denn das Frontend Source, Pages, ja, Pages,
okay das ist tatsächlich relativ komplex, aber immer noch, aber immer noch halbwegs
übersichtlich, ja nicht in C++ zum Glück, ich hatte mir vor, das wäre in C++, Certificate,
vielleicht gibt's ja dafür sogar schon ein Pullrequest oder so, zeigen wir mal, Issues,
Aspire Check, Renewal Configuration, Improved Certificate Info Display, Certificate Info
Error, ja gut, das ist wenn's schon abgelaufen ist, wenn's schon abgelaufen ist, ich will
ja haben, wenn es abläuft, Expire, how to add, ah hier isses, hier isses, ach ne, das
ist wie man ein Reverse Proxy da vormacht, okay ne, keine Ahnung, aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen, dass dann wirklich so was noch kommt, das wäre ja blöd, wenn das Certificate
checken kann, aber man sieht das nirgendswo, Alerts, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, das würde ich tatsächlich jetzt mal abwarten, was da noch kommt, aber an sich ist das doch
schon wirklich, wirklich nice, man weiß jetzt, okay, es läuft in einem Tag ab, mein klar,
es wäre cool, wenn es vielleicht in Orange anzeigt, aber ansonsten, wenn er anzeigt,
wenn es Expired, das ist ja auch erstmal gut, dann sucht man nicht den Fehler lange, sondern
sieht Aha, Zertifikat expired, schnell mal CertPort laufen lassen und es funktioniert
wieder, so, time, date, CTL, NTP, true, 0W, auf geht's, sollte jetzt hoffentlich NTP setzen,
ja, gut, stop, kannst du einen IP Stack Client für Ubuntu Server empfehlen, ehrlich gesagt
die einzigen Male, wo ich auf Ubuntu IP Stack verwenden wollte, da war das Cisco VPNC, aber
ich weiß nicht, ob man das heute noch verwendet, das ist auch schon Jahre, wirklich Jahre her,
aber es war VPNC, aber ich finde das Ding cool, das hat was, so, dann probieren wir nochmal
aus, was habe ich denn sonst noch, was ich bei mir überwachen muss, ja, ich könnte zum
Beispiel, ich habe hier intern so eine Testkiste, die einfach nur läuft, um zu laufen, zu gucken,
ob die Zertifikat Erneuerung funktioniert, UMI HTTPS, bam, add, safe, jawoll, funktioniert,
sehr gut, richtig pock, das Ding finde ich richtig gut, das ist simpel und du kannst
die wichtigsten Sachen machen, was wir mal ausprobieren müssen ist diese Push, diese
Webhook Geschichte, also, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, bei diesen ganzen Checks geht der
Raspberry Pi hin und überprüft, ob das Service funktioniert, bei, wir können übrigens den
Preisschamp noch einbauen, machen wir mal hier HTTPS, Preisschamp.org, können wir gleich
mal gucken, wann es expired, safe, und es expired in 50 Tagen, ok, mein automatisches
Let's Encrypt Setup funktioniert, funktioniert noch, oh, Flashbang, so, wie ist das mit den
Push Notifications, mal angenommen, ich habe jetzt ein, was wäre denn ein schönes Beispiel
für Push Notifications, nicht für Push Notifications, für Webhook oder für umgedreht, für Server
melden, alles ok, was gibt es denn da, wofür könnte ich das denn sinnvollerweise benutzen,
fällt mir jetzt gar nichts ein, der Preisschamp, nee, der hat ein, ich beleg mal, wie mach
ich es auf den Preisschamp, ich glaube auf dem Preisschamp habe ich ein Reverse Proxy
davor, der Zertifikatshandling macht, mir fällt jetzt gar kein Beispiel für ein, aber
ich könnte zum Beispiel sowas hier machen, KQ, save, KQ, und wenn ich jetzt hier einen
Curl davor mache, dann ist der Check ok, und wenn sich der Server nicht innerhalb von 60
Sekunden meldet, dann geht er eben auf rot, der Stream ist schon hochgeladen, das ist immer
automatisch bei Twitch da, in den Wots, also der sollte jetzt eigentlich in 60 Sekunden
wieder auf rot gehen, wenn sich der Server dann nicht mehr meldet, das ist eigentlich
ganz cool, aber ansonsten, also wenn das mit der Zertifikatsgeschichte, dass man besser
mitbekommt, wann Zertifikate ablaufen, gut Facebook läuscht mal wieder, das ist ja komplett
sinnlos, aber dass ich besser mitbekomme, wann Zertifikate ablaufen, so am besten irgendwie
7 Tage im Vorlauf, wenn die das noch ein bisschen verbessern, ist glaube ich echt alles drin,
was ich für meinen Heimbereich so brauche, weil du kommst mit Ping, HTTP und TCP-Checks
eigentlich 99% der Fälle hin, DNS, wüsste ich gar nicht, wann ich DNS-Checks machen
will, Steam Game Server juckt mich auch nicht, Push, Push ist vielleicht noch ganz interessant,
ja wenn du eigene Sensoren hast, die kannst du mit Push machen, genau, aber da wüsste
ich jetzt gar nicht, was ich machen will, ich könnte zum Beispiel das Ding, was meine
Heizung überwacht, da ab und zu mal Status pushen lassen oder irgendwas sinnloses, was
ist HTTPS Keyword, da kannst du gucken, ob in dem Body vom Request irgendein Schlüsselwort
drin vorkommt, siehst du, jetzt hat sich der Server innerhalb von 60 Sekunden nicht gemeldet
und zack, ist er down, jetzt meldet er sich wieder und dann ist er wieder ab, das ist
gut, ja den könnte ich zum Beispiel umstellen, von HTTPS auf HTTPS mit Keyword und ich weiß,
dass da in der Response, kurz gucken, ich weiß, dass da in der Response drinne steht
Hostname zum Beispiel, also wie sagen wir mal Keyword, überprüfen, ob das drinne ist,
ist down, oh nein, so Keyword, Hostname, muss drinne sein, haha, es ist ab, der checkt jetzt
ob im Response quasi was drinne vorkommt, was ganz praktisch sein kann, ich mein, das
ist alles kein Ersatz für irgendwie so das Business Stonks Enterprise Monitoring System,
also wenn man beispielsweise Anwendungszwecke hat für sowas wie Zabbix oder Metric gedönst
mit Prometheus Grafana oder sowas, da ist es natürlich kein Ersatz für, zumal Zabbix
ja auch noch viel mehr kann, Zabbix hast du die ganzen Fashion Templates, du kannst sogar
Actions auslösen, was das machen soll, wenn es denn down geht und sowas, aber das brauche
ich daheim gar nicht und ich wette mit euch, ihr braucht das daheim wahrscheinlich auch
nicht, ihr wollt wissen, ob die Kamera noch läuft, ihr wollt vielleicht wissen, ob in
Raspberry Pi auf dem Dachboden im Keller noch läuft und das höchste der Gefühle
ist zu gucken, ob irgendein Webservice läuft, ja genau, deswegen sag ich ja, Zabbix oder
auch von Nagios bis Checkmk und was es da noch alles gibt, das ist halt deutlich administrationsintensiver
als so ein Ding, das Ding braucht ja im Prinzip gar nichts, Docker Stats, warum auch immer,
ach Leute ich glaube ich weiß warum das keine Memory Usage anzeigt, hat der Raspberry Pi
keine Probleme, wenn man Docker Memory Limits setzen will, hat der nicht irgendwelche Kernel
Geschichten nicht, damit man Memory Limits setzen kann, das habe ich nämlich mal probiert
und das ging nicht und vielleicht kann er deswegen auch die Memory Usage nicht abfragen.
Welches Monitoring System kannst du empfehlen für komplexere Sachen?
Naja also ich hab, also was für Monitoring Systeme ich bisher verwendet hab ist, ich hab
in meiner Ausbildung und danach mich eine ganze Weile um Nagios gekümmert, deswegen hab ich
immer noch ein Herz für Nagios und Nagios ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm, ich
find Nagios an sich ganz cool, ich würd sagen der große Vorteil von Nagios ist, dass es
einfach erweiterbar ist, besser als alles andere, du kannst ja im Prinzip alles mit
einem Skript, was drei verschiedene Rückgabewerte hat abfackeln, so Up, Down oder Crit, ne was
war das?
Du hattest irgendwie drei Rückgabewerte bei Nagios, genau Warning, Warning, Critical,
ok.
So, also Nagios hab ich ganz lange verwendet, ist aber jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr die Super
Bleeding Edge Systeme, damit hab ich schon nie gearbeitet und auf der Arbeit haben wir
eine Kombination aus Zappix und Prometheus, Grafana, ich hab auch schon mal ein paar Alternativen
dazu ausprobiert, ich hab auch schon mal diese Influx, DB, Chronograph, Telegraph Mischung
da ausprobiert, aber ich muss sagen, ich komm am besten mit Prometheus klar und Grafana
als Dashboard, wenns um sowas geht und wie gesagt wir haben auf der Arbeit auch die Kombination
von Prometheus, Grafana, Zappix und für Logs Elastic Surge, ja es gibt ganz viele
Dinge, Libre NMS, Open NMS, Nagios, Zappix, es gibt 100.000 dieser Sachen, die haben alle
ihre Vor- und Nachteile.
Prometheus ist halt so ein Ding, mit Prometheus und Grafana du kannst im Prinzip alles irgendwie
machen aber es ist eindeutig dafür ausgelegt, dass man Metriken abfragt aus eigener Software
oder eben aus Software die Metriken zur Verfügung stellt, da glänzt das halt, wenn man eigene
Java Software hat oder eigene.NET Software, die dann Informationen zur Verfügung stellt
und ich will dann wissen, wie entwickeln sich die Connection Pools über den Tag, wie
entwickelt sich mein User Account über den Tag, dafür ist Prometheus, Grafana richtig
gut, ich finde für so reines Is-Up-Down Monitoring, ist Prometheus und Grafana zwar möglich aber
nicht die Stärke.
Dann musste nämlich in Prometheus und Grafana, musste dann so Dinge behandeln wie Ping-Up-Down,
Agent-Up-Down, SSH-Reachable, Not-Reachable, dann hast du die Geschichten, dass Up-Down
vielleicht bei einem Switch ein anderes Up-Down ist als bei einem Desktop mit einem Agent
installiert, dann musst du extra Yammel-Files für Blackbox-Exporter machen und sowas, das
finde ich nicht schön.
Also Prometheus, Grafana ist richtig gut, wenn du viele Daten hast, die du aufbereiten
willst grafisch, aber für so reines, wie nennt man das, Verfügbarkeitsanzeige, Up-Down, ist
es nicht so geil.
Und die Gebiete verschwimmen ja auch ein bisschen spätestens, wenn du sagst, hey, du willst
beispielsweise auf ein Betriebssystem Festplattenauslastung überprüfen und ab einem gewissen Schwellwert
warnen.
Warnungen sind in Prometheus, Grafana auch so ein Ding.
Du hast den Alert-Manager, wo du dann auch irgendwelche Rules konfigurieren musst.
Ich finde, das ist alles, das geht alles, aber schön, ja, kann man sich jetzt drüber
streiten.
Also für so klassische Monitoring-Sachen, Systeme überwachen und ist Up, ist Down,
ist Reachable und nicht, da finde ich die hier persönlich deutlich, aber wobei das
habe ich noch nie wirklich verwendet, da finde ich die besser als Prometheus und dafür,
wenn du irgendwelche Metriken und Trends vererkennen und analysieren willst, da ist
das gut.
Zappix kann mittlerweile alles irgendwie, dementsprechend ist es aber, also kannst in Zappix ja auch
mittlerweile Prometheus-Sachen importieren und sowas, aber ganz ehrlich, Zappix ist eh
schon das komplexeste Ding von den ganzen.
Ja man kann es auch deutsch aussprechen, das ist alles, zumindest bei Checkmk ist die
Basic-Variante kostenlos bei Nagios auch, bei Zappix auch, Prometheus ist eh prinzipiell
kostenlos, Grafana auch, ja, aber die Frage ist, was du halt überwachen willst, also
sprich wo sind deine Schwerpunkte, möchtest du SNMP Netzwerksachen überwachen, möchtest
du Cloud-Services überwachen, möchtest du Anwendungen-Metriken überwachen, dass du
beispielsweise weißt, fuck auf einmal haben wir 2000 User mehr als sonst, also das ist
die eigentliche Frage, also wenn du ein bisschen genauer sagst, was du überwachen willst,
dann können wir dir vielleicht auch da besser was zu empfehlen.
Benutzt man in C-Sharp noch Pointer, man hat in C-Sharp quasi schon immer und noch nie
Pointer benutzt, also die Unterstützung Pointer Unsave war seit C-Sharp 1 drinne, aber man
benutzt das quasi kaum, außer man sagt, dass generell Funktionsaufruf mit Referenz quasi
schon Pointer sind, dann benutzt du permanent Pointer in C-Sharp, aber das würde ich so
nicht sehen.
Also die reine Pointer-Geschichte, da musst du Unsave verwenden in C-Sharp, das kann man
machen, aber ist selten.
Also Zabbix probieren ist wirklich nicht so ohne, also Zabbix hat hohen Komplexitätsgrad,
also das hier in Zabbix einzurichten, brauchst du erstmal 2 Tage, wenn du es auch nie gemacht
hast.
Also wenn du nicht genau weißt, was du überwachen willst und einfach nur wissen willst, ist
was ab oder down, dann ist das hier mit Abstand das simpelste, was ich je gesehen habe.
Hier, da war sogar mal down zwischendurch, was, das kannst du doch einfach abfragen,
da gibt es doch environment, was für sich environment ist 64bit oder so, ja die Sache
mit Agents ist nämlich auch so ein Ding, damit Prometheus ordentlich funktioniert, brauchst
du den Nodexporter für das System oder halt Nodexporter in die Anwendung einbauen und
willst du so Sachen überwachen wie, was weiß ich, du hast dann ESP32 an der Klingel und
willst wissen, ob das funktioniert, dann ist das ja mit Exporter doof, deswegen brauchst
du dann wieder so ein Blackbox Exporter, der auf dem eigentlichen Prometheus Host mitläuft,
das finde ich doof.
Und auf dem ESP32 installierst du dann auch einfach keinen Monitoring Agent und auf dem
Switch auch nicht, da machst du es ja meistens per SNMP oder irgendwelchen anderen Geschichten.
Ja es ist tatsächlich ein, also System Monitoring ist wirklich ein Gebiet, das ist komplexer
als man denkt, also da muss man schon genau gucken, was man machen will, man kann mit
fast jedem System fast alles machen, es ist bloß die Frage, ob man sich dabei die Finger
verbringt oder nicht.
Du hast ein Home Automation Problem, ich habe einen dummen Luftbefeuchter und würde diesen
gerne über Home Assistant steuern, je nach Luftfeuchtigkeit ein aus.
Habe an einem Smart Hygrometer und eine flashbare Steckdose, also ich bin Luftbefeuchter, gedacht,
kannst du mir Tipps geben, ob die konkreten Artikel, welche sich eigentlich flashbar
sind?
Äh ja das weiß man nicht, also das Problem ist, wenn du dir Steckdosen kaufst bei Amazon,
da musst du in den Bewertungen gucken, ob da irgendeiner geschrieben hat, er hat in letzter
Zeit mit Tasmota geflashed, die Chancen sinken aber immer weiter, das hat zwei Gründe, einmal
ist die Firma Version aktueller und sie lässt sich nicht mehr so einfach flashen, dann kannst
du es aber immer noch aufschrauben und den ESP32 flashen oder ESP266 flashen, aber das
eigentliche Problem ist, dass die Hersteller mittlerweile Geräte bauen, die keinen ESP
mehr drin haben und das ist das nächste was ich sagen wollte, es gibt aber auch Preflashed
Sachen, da muss man sich überlegen, du kannst dir aber auch gleich irgendeine Shelley Geschichte
oder so kaufen, wenn es ein paar Euro teurer sein darf, die haben schon eine Firmware drauf,
die kannst du von Homesystem und allem ansprechen, ansonsten Luftfeuchtigkeit, Thermometer und
sowas gibt es jede Menge Sensoren, ist das wie bei Foxconn, wo die Leute dann vom Dach
springen, ich weiß nicht ob das so ein geiler Benefit ist, Windows Server Monitoring habe
ich noch nie gemacht, hoffe ich auch, dass ich das nie machen muss, ist mir der neue
Nextcloud drauf, ich weiß jetzt schon was passiert, wenn ich Nextcloud ausprobiere,
ich sage es ist im Ansatz ganz gut, aber es ist in der Umsetzung wieder nur halb fertig,
das ist ein bisschen wie Battlefield 2042, also im Prinzip ist Nextcloud so das Battlefield
2042 der Software Dinger, vieles in Ansätzen gut, aber fast nichts zu Ende gedacht, ok was
haben sie denn gemacht, what's new, Nextcloud Files, Massive Syncing Performance Improvements,
ok das ist schonmal gut, Groupware ist komplett useless für mich, das brauche ich nicht,
Appointment Booking, Room Booking, das ist so Business Zeug, das ist für mich daheim
vollkommen irrelevant, Nextcloud Talk braucht auch kein Mensch, also doch aber ich nicht,
Nextcloud Office brauche ich auch nicht, ja super, es ist wieder nichts dabei, außer
die Performance Improvements für mich, also im Prinzip ist es immer noch unfertig für
das was ich heute will, zumal die Volltex, ist es ein Toss Bild was man hier nebenbei
sieht, nee, sagt kann so ein bisschen so aus, es ist bestimmt immer noch keine Volltex Suche
standardmäßig mit dabei, da muss man wieder Elastic Search oder was das war in der zusätzlichen
Kiste laufen lassen, was wieder kein Noob checkt, ja genau, ich
dünke noch auf Nextcloud, aber ich will Nextcloud wie gesagt schon längere Zeit loswerden,
ich bin kein großer Nextcloud Fan, ne die werden ja ganz normal über Amazon.de vertrieben,
also denke nicht, dass da jetzt größere Chancen bestehen, dass die abfackeln wie
was anderes, aber das finde ich richtig gut, das ist nice, das gefällt mir gut, das hat
was, das werde ich dann gleich mal installieren, Offstream und für so die wichtigsten Sachen
bei mir daheim einrichten, das finde ich richtig gut hier, guck mal CAC V ist ab, jetzt ist
es raus.
Ach mir fällt gerade noch was ein, mir fällt gerade noch was ein, weil ich doch am Anfang
gesagt habe, wenn man hier refresht, wo ich gerade so in mich gegangen bin, wenn man refresht
sieht man noch das weiß durchschimmern, das lag nicht nur daran, das lag an zwei Sachen,
jetzt weiß ich wieder, einmal man durfte nicht das App themen, sondern muss body themen
und was ich ganz vergessen habe vorhin noch, man musste Vue.js sagen es soll blocken bis
es komplett geladen ist, da gab es irgendwie was war das loaded oder so, loaded event,
es gab irgendeinen flag was man setzen konnte, bei Vue beim page rendern, dass der wartet
bis alles geladen ist, ich weiß nicht ob das loaded war, irgendwas in der richtung, das
musste man auch noch dran schreiben und dann hatte man nicht mehr dieses geflacker bei
reload von der darksteam seite.
Was für eine linius distro ist das, das ist man jaro mit i3 wm, könnte man ein bisschen
aufräumen wieder hier trash gucken, seit wann zeigt der das an, was will der da löschen,
monkaS, ich weiß nicht genau was der da alles löschen will, Sachen in boot, der dns stellz
kann nicht entfernt werden Leute, ok keine ahnung, das ist so ein papierkop ding was
ich mir mal installiert habe, was rm replaced, weil ich ab und zu mal mit rm schon dumme
sachen getrieben habe, ich hab beispielsweise mal über ssh mal das heimatverzeichnis von
meinem notebook gelöscht, da war ich von daheim per ssh auf der arbeit immer notebook eingeloggt
und hab rm-rf gemacht und irgendwie mist eingetippt und dann hab ich mein heimatverzeichnis
gelöscht, ich hab dann wichtigste sachen hab ich wieder rausgecrept auf devsda, ganz wirr,
aber seitdem hab ich das replaced mit trash, genau, das war nicht so sinnig, ja das sind
die dinger, da hab ich auch welche, die kann man flashen, die kann man flashen, da gibts
open source software auf github für, die sind sogar ganz gut, allerdings was du dir
überlegen könntest, nachdem das ja alles bei dir in der nähe ist und netzanschluss
hat, da würd ich vielleicht irgendwas anderes nehmen, weil du willst ja keine batterien
wechseln, dann würd ich vielleicht wirklich irgendeinen was weiß ich irgendeinen anderen
sensor nehmen, also zum thema luftfeuchtigkeit gibt es total viel, im zweifelsfall nimmst
du nen esp mit irgendeinem dht 22 oder so, oder wie heißt dieses ding von bosch, luftfeuchtigkeit
temperatur und luftdrucksensor bpm bbmpe, sensornamen aus dem kopf, bmets, guck mal
der chat, der chat ist so feifett, ich laber irgendwas vor mich hin und die wissen was
ich meine, genau dieses ding meine ich, das ist luftdruck, luftfeuchtigkeit und temperatursensor,
was eigentlich ziemlich nice ist, kann man sich zumindest nicht beschweren, richtig spog,
spog, ähm, zähl musik aus
oh guck mal mein video wird empfohlen, das muss ich doch gleich mal anmachen und
laufen lassen, dass ich viewtime krieg, ne das ist zu viel, ich weiß gar nicht warum
das so teuer ist bei amazon gerade, also die sind natürlich teurer als die dht dinger
aber die sind auch genauer, guck mal die aliexpress chinesen, 82 cent easy, amazon sagt, was ist
denn mit denen los, was ist der unterschied zwischen dem und dem, das ist wahrscheinlich
spi und das ist sqc oder umgedreht oder, ach ne das ist der eine ist der bmp oder andere
ist der bme, ja ne der ist für den preis, für den preis wird das nicht dem, was sagen
denn die chinesen, ja du brauchst auf jeden fall ja luftfeuchtigkeit hast du gesagt, ja
da sind wir doch eher in preisregionen die interessanter sind, ach guck mal es sind nur
862.161 verfügbar, na das wird aber knapp, ah das ist halt wieder, guck mal das, äh
chinesen sind wieder, merkwürdig, moment ich soll 30 euro mehr bezahlen und krieg das
noch später, dhl 100 euro, alles klar, natürlich, natürlich, 10 stück 100 euro dhl versand,
sehr gut, aliexpress ist mal wieder, ist mal wieder aliexpress, man plickt wieder nicht
durch, aber wie gesagt dafür würde ich nicht so viel, gibts das irgendwie bei reichelt
oder so, ja, da kommen wir der sache, kommen wir der sache ja schon näher oder auch nicht,
konrad, könntest du direkt auf die zeile abholen, wave share, was ist das, ja please
noch mehr, ach das ist so mit so nem extra, ja gut wenn mans braucht warum nicht, es ist
grad wirklich schwer ranzukommen an den ganzen kram oder, warum ist das, ich weiß noch ich
hab hier noch irgendwo nen 10er pack, ja leute, ich kann nur sagen richtig pogger software,
die andere müssen wir gar nicht ausprobieren, beste, ich hab jetzt aber überhaupt nix mehr
was ich noch machen könnte, welche wäre die andere gewesen hier, stats ping ng, aber ich
vermute mal, also erstens ist das projekt nicht so beliebt, wurde erst letztens geforkt
und das andere kann er einfach mehr, mach mal ein incident in der status page, edit, create
incident, titel, lull down, keck, danger, oh, light, dark, primary, warning, post, bam,
save, von ks, die seite, ich hab sie, ich hab sie geprägt, lull down, keck, ja gut das
ist die seite die man anzeigen würde wenn man jetzt nach außen hin irgendwie die verfügbarkeit
seiner systeme anzeigen möchte, ja und drüber schreiben möchte, ha wir wissen, bescheid,
das ist dann so die typische meldung wo drin steht, lull down wir arbeiten mit hochdruck
an der lösung des problemes oder sowas, techniker ist informiert genau, aber das ist wirklich
cool also mir gefällt die software richtig gut, gerade für so heimmonitoring kram ist
es doch wunderbar, es reicht doch für alles, leute wir liken, wir liken den einfach mal,
aber ich bin nicht eingeloggt, ok, ich leike den nicht, bin ich eingeloggt, ok, seinen,
wo bloß, ne weiß ich jetzt aus dem kopf nicht, keine ahnung, aber kann man mal liken,
ne aber nicht so das das nötig hätte, ich mein guck mal der hat schon 10.000 sterne,
das ist richtig poc, entstanden auf dem hacktoberfest anscheinend, guck mal kurz in das, ich will
noch mal ganz kurz in das frontend reingucken, pages, dashboard details, ha wir wollen es
ja eigentlich im dashboard sehen, components monitor list, aha, boah das ist ja richtig
komplexe view styles hier, da müsste ich jetzt wirklich erst ein bisschen suchen, dass ich
checke, wo man das anzeigen lassen kann, dass es bald expired, na das wäre ja schon nice,
wenn jetzt sagen wir mal hier drinnen stehen würde oder wenn das hier sagen wir mal auf
orange geht, wenn, keine ahnung, sieben tage verbleiben bis zertifikat expired sind, ist
das auch tailwind, das ist ne gute frage was das ist, ja gut kein schimmer da erkennt
man es schon mal nicht, müssen wir mal hier gucken, schauen wir mal was der da verwendet,
wobei es gab doch diese coole seite, ah moment ich weiß was, wir können doch, demo, punkt
pet powers, es gab doch diese analyse was das produkt verwendet, war das hier in den,
boah browser tools alter, meinst du das firefox oder chrome, ich glaube das gab es in chrome,
da konnte man sich noch anzeigen lassen was das alles verwendet, admin 123456, ach nee
123456 gab es ja nicht und ich habe das admin password nicht gespeichert Leute, ich weiß
das admin password nicht mal, könntet ihr es nicht ausprobieren, ja wir gucken mal kurz
was das verwendet, wie kriegen wir das jetzt am besten raus was das benutzt, public, package
j8, das habe ich, danach habe ich gerade geguckt aber das sehe ich hier nicht oder hat er das
hier oben drüber, ach so ich dachte das ist fürs backend, ich dachte das ist fürs backend,
nee das ist für alles, ok es ist schon was relativ neues, simple, nein das ist kein tailwind,
das ist wahrscheinlich gar nichts davon, das ist selbst gebastelt das css, post css, das
ist ein selbst gebasteltes css, was ist denn die index seite überhaupt, war das bootstrap,
ach nee das ist der programmierer davon, es ist bootstrap Leute, es ist bootstrap, ja warum
auch nicht, warum nicht, wobei ich da ganz ehrlich sagen muss, das design ist ja schon
recht minimalistisch, ich glaube dafür bräuchte man eigentlich auch kein bootstrap, ich glaube
das würde man auch noch so hinbekommen, wobei man ja tailwind und bootstrap ähnlich vergleichen
kann, tailwind ist ja quasi mehr css für inline html, mehr für inline css, ohne dass
das jetzt irgendwelche fertigen komponenten sind im vergleich zu bootstrap, ja Leute also
ich hab nix mehr, gibt nix, bin fertig für heute, aber haben wir richtig gute software
gefunden, richtig pock das thing, massive pock, pockers, da gibt es jetzt halo, nee
jetzt geh ich aufs klo, wusstest du, das hab ich letztens schonmal irgendwo gelesen,
ja, nee, ne finish bestimmt auch wieder auf github, nicht auf github alle, auf youtube,
toll, ja man kann auch eine telegram benachrichtigung einstellen, man kann notification von telegram
über webhooks bis email, discord, teams, signal, goteify, das ist irgendwie so ein android
den in go programmiert fragt mir nicht slack rocket chat pushover pushy
octo push promo sms klickset sms luna hab ich nie gehört
feischu auch noch nie gehört ali jun sms hab ich auch noch nie gehört das
kenne ich auch nicht pusht bullet kenne ich leitmesse der meta maus matrix
ding ding ding ding und bark busch luna sieh habe ich schon nie gehört
warum haben die keine icq ich wollte da hätte ich mich mal wieder
nachrichten gekriegt auf icq discord discord webhook da könne ich in mein
discord rein posten wenn bei mir der raspberry pi down gegangen ist das
interessiert war ja bestimmt super super krass das wollt ihr bestimmt schon
immer wissen kein kein jammer und kein msn ja legacy technologie wie das
scoreboard in battlefield alles legacy technologie ioc eine akut also wenn
eins legacy technologie ist dann wohl ioc oder
ioc ist der inbegriff von legacy technologie twitch benachrichtigung ja
das sollte sein
doch der twitch chat kann man sich auch bei lsc connecten
twitch chat ist sowas von legacy gut leute ich gehe jetzt auf wir sehen uns
war es gut bis denn zu